Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Test, Test, Kunst.
Windows Sound weiß man ja nie.
Übrigens, mein Headset hat sich wieder von selbst gefixt.
Ich hatte doch vor ein paar Wochen das Problem, dass es auf der einen Seite ein bisschen lauter war als auf der anderen Seite.
Oh, ich muss mal gucken, nicht, dass ich hier noch...
Nicht, dass ich hier noch Windows-Sound-Settings habe und es deswegen der Fall ist...
Spauen wir mal kurz, wenn ich es finde.
Weil die Windows-Sound-Settings sind immer super versteckt.
Wie war das jetzt nochmal? Lass mal überlegen.
Ich glaube, Control Panel ist halt auch absolut affig, ne?
Hardware und Sound.
Wenn du denkst, das sind viele Tabs.
Warte mal ab.
Ich habe hier Tabs.
Guck mal hier, bei den Tabs reicht...
Ist doch nicht mal mal ein Text.
Und wenn ich die VM gleich einschalte...
Äh, ne, nicht die VM.
Den Mini-PC, da habe ich nochmal viele Tabs.
Hier.
Sound.
Output.
Levels.
Balance.
Ne, ist alles gleich.
Also ich meine, ihr müsst...
Was das für eine Click-Orgie ist, oder?
bis man überhaupt da angekommen ist.
Und man muss vor allem wissen,
man könnte ja
vermuten, es würde über diesen Soundbutton
hier unten gehen. Ne, ist aber nicht so.
Soundbutton ist
outdated, overrated, cheapated.
Übrigens, was auch witzig ist,
wenn man hier auf Sound drückt,
kommt überhaupt kein Sound mehr. Nur wenn man
rechts klickt
und hier ist Soundset, also ganz ehrlich,
was die sich da aussehen, ist wirklich voll
der Witz.
Ja, das Schlimme ist,
das Schlimme ist, mit RAM ausnutzen,
die meisten
Tabs verbrauchen gar keinen RAM,
weil die gar nicht geladen werden.
Wenn du den Browser neu aufmachst
und stellst die letzte Session wieder her,
guck,
der lädt teilweise, na gut,
jetzt hat das die ersten Partner geladen,
der lädt teilweise erst,
da fuck, was haben wir denn hier offen?
Wenn du die wirklich aufmachst.
Das ist im Endeffekt nur nicht mal der RAM
wird ausgelastet.
Und ich hätte gern mal einen RAM ausgelastet.
Weil ich hab so viel RAM.
Ich weiß First World Problems
im Jahr 2026.
Aber ich hab so viel RAM
damals gekauft. Und der ist nie ausgelastet.
Guck mal. Ich hab
Ich hab
64 GB RAM.
Kostet wahrscheinlich mehr als
der ganze Rechner.
Ne.
Hab ich immer noch nicht.
Die Kiste hat immer noch 8 GB RAM, der Mini-PC.
Aber in der Regel reicht es ja.
Es fehlt auch nicht am Geld.
Ich war irgendwie immer zu faul dazu, RAM zu ordern.
Zur Not baue ich einfach RAM aus einer Nasskiste aus.
Muss auch Pillen nehmen.
Wartet mal kurz.
Pillen schnell.
Ich habe gar nichts vergessen.
Oh.
Excellent.
Gigarich bin ich bestimmt nicht.
Das meiste Geld, was ich hab,
liegt in einem World ETF.
Dass der in ein paar Jahren noch mehr
Stonks abwirft.
Irgendwo muss die Kohle ja hin.
Max heute wieder vegan stellt
Ne
Heute gibt es den Rest von gestern
Gestern gab es
So
Tiefkühl Fischstücke
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie große
Wie große Fischstäbchen
Und Kartoffelsalat
Also nicht vegan
Max, interessierst du dich für Gameboy-Emulationen?
Naja.
Also es ist jetzt nicht was, wo ich aktiv danach gucke.
Gibt wenig Gameboy-Spiele, die ich unbedingt spielen möchte nochmal.
Mensch, muss gerade mal die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen.
Aber was mich durchaus interessieren könnte ist, was es da für neue technische Entwicklungen gibt, falls du darauf anspielst.
Lachsnudel habe ich schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr gefuttert.
Aber wie gesagt, ich esse in letzter Zeit mehr vegan.
Vegetarisch, muss nicht unbedingt vegan sein.
Also was zum Beispiel richtig gut schmeckt, was mir fast besser schmeckt als echtes Hackfleisch,
ist veganes Hackfleisch mit Spaghetti.
Tomatensoße, Spaghetti, veganes Hackfleisch.
Das schmeckt mir fast besser als das echte Hackfleisch.
Ich frage, weil ich aktuell an einem Emulator bastle, hab da versucht eine Foxel-Grafik
einzubauen.
Ist noch Alpha.
Wenn du willst, kannst du GitHub-Repos schicken und wir gucken mal rein.
Ein bisschen Werbung machen.
Für alle, die Bock haben, das auszuprobieren.
Da kann ich mal angucken, wie schön dein C++-Code ist.
Ich vermute jetzt einfach mal, es ist C++.
Aber in welcher Sprache ist das denn?
Go. In Go.
Oh, das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Na doch, Primär C++.
Ich habe gedacht, das ist in Go, weil da Go steht.
Also ich habe jetzt einfach mal auf C++ getippt.
Nicht, weil ich großer C++-Fan bin.
Ihr wisst, ich arbeite daran, der größte C++-Hater zu werden.
Aber so Dinger sind halt gerne in C++.
Auch wenn C++ eine richtige Scheißsprache ist, Alter.
Achso.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal ins Emulator-CPP.
Ähm.
Seit wann gibt es einen in C++ Question Mark Operator für Fehler?
Ach, nee.
Das ist ein If.
Ich hab den Doppelpunkt nicht gesehen
Das ist ein If
Ich hab gedacht es wär so ein bisschen Rust Style
Hardware Model Automatic
Wenn Fehler dann
Ne ne ne das ist ein If
Das ist ja mal tatsächlich richtig ordentliches C++ hier
CPU
CPU CPP da ist bestimmt viel drin
Einfach Rust Lover werden, dann bist du automatisch C++ Hater
Ich war auch schon vorher C++ Hater
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich wirklich Rust Lover bin
Aber ich bin auf jeden Fall C++ Hater
Das ist sehr ordentliches C++
Das kann man direkt lesen
Das ist gar nicht so typisches C++
So übelst verschachteltes, ekliges Zeug
Na gut, gegen ein bisschen eklige C++-Sonntags,
da kannst du ja nichts dagegen machen.
Aber das ist richtig gut zu lesen.
Ich meine, so gut zu lesen,
so low-level Gramm halt sein kann.
Ja, weil letztendlich ist das halt alles Magic.
Man kann es lesen, man weiß, was es macht,
aber was es wirklich macht, weiß man trotzdem nicht,
wenn man sich nicht mit einer Plattform auseinandergesetzt hat.
Ey, das ist die CD.
Also wirklich...
Da würde ich mir zutrauen, wenn ich mir das lange durchlese,
vielleicht halbwegs zu verstehen, um was es geht.
Ja, sehr hübsches C++.
Also Leute, falls einer Bock hat, einen neuen Game Boy Emulator auszuprobieren,
gibt es denn schon Releases?
Gibt es.
Gibt es sogar...
Gibt es sogar Linux x86, x86, x86.
x64 binaries oder oder oder ist es nur das aus code das ist ein binary drin oder
eine arbeit kann ich mir vorstellen c++ binary habe ich mal habe ich war eine frage wie hast
du das gemacht?
Konntest du alles staatlich linken?
Weil du so gut wie keine Dependencies hast?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das bei einem
Gameboy-Emulator tatsächlich
vielleicht SDL oder sowas,
ich weiß nicht, was du für Dependency hast,
sich halbwegs in Grenzen hält.
By the way,
ich habe immer das Problem, bei C++-Projekten
zu finden, was man für Dependencies hat.
CMake-List?
Wo sehe ich das?
ok keine keine ahnung ist es ist immer gut geraten oder aber stl kam
wahrscheinlich gut ist der klinken also hast wahrscheinlich ein statisches
binary weil ganz ehrlich linux binaries bauen also linux binaries die auf
möglichst viel distribution laufen ist ab hoch 10
Ich habe da meine Erfahrung gemacht mit.
Sofern man alles statisch linken kann, ist das kein Problem.
Aber sobald du Abhängigkeiten hast auf GLibc oder sowas vom System,
dann wird es abartig.
Dann musst du ein Binary machen gegen Dynamisch GLibc,
ein Binary Dynamisch gegen Muselibc
oder du machst es komplett statisch, was dann aber
wieder nicht geht, wenn du dynamisch Sachen nachladen willst.
Also ganz ehrlich,
das ist übelste Abfrage.
Asahi Linux kann jetzt
M3 Macs. Okay, ist das gut oder
schlecht? Also so wie du das schreibst,
ist es wahrscheinlich gut.
Aber wenn ich ein Mac habe,
warum sollte ich
darauf Linux verwenden, anstatt
das System, was
darauf läuft, was man sich
Command-Line-Technisch, sag mal
Linux-ähnlich genug einrichten kann, dass es
nicht nervt. Dann hast du den vollen Support
vom Hersteller. Also ich glaube, wenn ich ein MacBook
hätte, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich wirklich
macOS drauf verwenden und mir halt Terminal-mäßig
alles so einrichten, wie ich es brauche.
Übrigens, Chat-Gip. Also Leute,
ich poste nochmal das Projekt
in den Chat. Also wenn einer
Bock hat, hier, machen wir Releases,
Gameboy-Emulator auszuprobieren.
Von jemand aus dem
Chat.
Gibt es sogar für Android.
Ne, doch, oder?
Android.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen APK und AAB?
Ist das mit Debugging gedöhnt, oder was?
Oder wie?
AAB ist neu.
Das heißt, neue Android-Packages
oder der Binary Packages, neue Android Packages sind nicht mehr APK, oder wie?
Exzellent.
APK ist deprecated.
Was machen denn dann diese ganzen komischen
PayDi-APK-Download-Seiten,
die APK im Namen haben?
Die werden sich doch nicht in der AAB umbenennen.
Sag mal,
Chat,
ist das einfach nur Zufall,
dass die Packages bei Alpine
auch APK heißen?
Oder hat das irgendwas miteinander zu tun?
Nee, oder? Das ist einfach nur Zufall.
Da bist du nicht der Einzige.
Also, ich meine, du musst ja das UI komplett selbst malen.
Mit SDL.
Oder benutzt du, wie heißt das, im GUI oder irgendwie sowas?
Oder malst du wirklich pixelmäßig das GUI selbst in das Fenster dann rein?
Weil da musst du ja wirklich
alles komplett selber malen.
Also ich scheitere ja schon regelmäßig dran,
mit HTML und CSS
hübsche Guis zu machen.
Dann würde ich
wahrscheinlich hier komplett abkacken.
Wenn ich alles selber trauen müsste.
Vor allem, du musst ja nicht nur die Sachen selber trauen.
Du musst ja auch noch gucken, dass der State irgendwie halbwegs dazu passt.
Also du musst dir dann wirklich merken, hier in dieser Pixel, da wird ein Button dargestellt und dieser Button wurde jetzt geklickt.
Das stelle ich mir ultra abfuckmäßig vor.
Und dazu musst du gucken, dass es bei jedem Frame auch noch ordentlich gemalt wird und auch die Regionen geupdatet werden.
Wobei, wenn du jeden Frame neu malst, geht's.
Aber trotzdem übst du ab, fuck.
Ja, ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Hast du schon GPT-6 Astra gesehen?
Ich hab gesehen, dass das released wurde.
Ich hab mich noch überhaupt null damit beschäftigt.
Gar nicht.
Ich habe nur ein FireShip Video gesehen, dass die angeblich jetzt AGI erreicht haben oder sowas.
Aber FireShip AI Videos, da weißt du ja nie, ob da auch wirklich das drinsteckt, was draufsteht.
Also ich habe in letzter Zeit jetzt öfters mal Opus 5 verwendet.
ich habe hier so eine so eine sammel ki so ein sammel ki abo wurde zehn euro im
monat bezahlt und dann kannst du alle möglichen models verwenden natürlich
nicht unlimited ist klar ja aber das limit reset sich jeden tag und da ist
alles mögliche drin da ist kimi drin da ist opus drin da ist wir können ja mal
kurz gucken. Also ich habe ja die hier.
So, und die haben
letztendlich den ganzen Mist hier drin.
Und ich habe in letzter
Zeit hier tatsächlich öfters mal hier
Opus 5 verwendet.
Und da sind ja alle
super krass begeistert von.
Und das ist in Benchmarks ganz vorn
und so. Und ich sage mal,
Ja, das ist nicht übel.
Aber das zieht sich auch ganz viele Sachen immer noch so aus dem Arsch.
Oder wie man es nennen soll.
So aus dem Ärmel.
So an den Haaren herbei.
Ich habe mir gestern beispielsweise angeguckt, wie man ein USB-Gerät mit Rust anspricht.
Das machen wir heute oder morgen vielleicht im Stream.
Ich habe gestern den Streamtitel schon geändert, aber dann habe ich doch lieber offline ein bisschen gebastelt.
Und ich habe das Problem, dass so eins von zehnmal starten das USB-Device überhaupt nicht respondet.
Also das readet einfach nichts.
Ganz merkwürdig.
und da habe ich
da habe ich dann
Opus 5 gefragt
und das hat sich
kompletten Kram aus, ich habe
den einfach mal in Source Code reingepacet,
das hängt bei jedem 10. Start so ungefähr,
das hat sich komplettes Ding an den
Haaren herbeigezogen, jetzt Sachen
die erstmal realistisch klingen,
aber halt überhaupt nicht realistisch sind,
ja, so irgendwelche
ähm, Threat
Deadlocks oder
irgendwie falsche
Initialisierungsreihenfolge.
Da muss ich ihm auch sagen, alter Opus,
das geht.
Das ist immer, das funktioniert,
das kann nicht die falsche Initialisierungsreihenfolge sein.
Und es liegt auch nicht
an Threads. Ich habe das umgestellt, dass es nur noch
mit einem Thread läuft.
Und das hat sich dann weiter
irgendwelche Dinge aus den Fingern gesaugt.
Ich tippe aktuell daran, dass
irgendein Bug entweder in der USB-Library ist
oder von meinem Device.
Aber damit kann ich leben.
Ist das so?
Ich habe keinen Vergleich.
Ich habe keinen...
Also doch, ich habe einen Vergleich.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit auch einen...
einen Abo.
Aber das ist ein Azure.
Ein Azure KI oder sowas Abo.
Und darüber kann man auch
GPT und Opus
und Gedöns verwenden.
Da habe ich jetzt nicht viel Unterschied gemerkt.
Möglich wäre natürlich, dass wenn du wirklich den Service direkt bei Anthropic kaufst
und das darüber machst, dass die dann auch irgendwie ein paar Besonderheiten freischalten oder so.
Vielleicht, ja.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe den direkten Vergleich nicht gemacht.
Vielleicht hat es ja auch einen Grund, warum die günstiger sind.
Vielleicht sucken die Models ja.
Wobei, die hosten die Models ja auch nicht selbst, sondern schicken das nur zu mir bei
LingHersteller.
Gar keinen.
Ich habe einfach den Source-Code, der war ja nicht lang,
in Chat gepostet.
Ich meine nur ein paar Zeilen.
Was ich halt nicht machen kann, ist
fragen,
hier finde mal raus, warum das hängt
und das in der Schleife laufen lassen.
Kannst du mal Trust Pilot...
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Gute Idee.
Aha.
Reject all.
Ähm.
Hä?
warning das ist gern warum
als auswählendes model ist verwendet
manche kommen sind wir haben okay wir kommen uns mal die einst dinge an
They use AI for support.
Alter, der wundert sich ernsthaft, warum
eine AI-Company AI für den Support verwendet.
Ja, würde mich aber auch abfacken.
Äh, doch, machen sie.
Okay, aber Fable 5 gibt es doch gar nicht mehr, oder?
Es ist doch jetzt Opus 5.
Oder bringe ich das durcheinander?
Okay.
Weiß nicht.
Das ist auch schon alles ein bisschen länger her, ne?
Keine Ahnung.
Also bis jetzt ist es ganz okay.
Aber vielleicht sollte ich mir wirklich einfach mal
eine Anthropic Lizenz kaufen.
Abo kaufen.
Und mal wirklich testen.
Den Unterschied dazwischen.
Ja, können wir machen.
So, chat.
Dann würde ich sagen
Selfmade Ice, danke schön für den Sub
Äh, habe ich vorhin Subscriptions übersehen sogar
Lass mich mal kurz checken
Ne, ne, ne, ich wurde nur 5 mal ans Trinken erinnert
Excellent, sehr gut
Selfmade Ice, danke schön für den Sub
Huge Subscriptions
Nice
Okay, wir machen mal den Mini-PC an.
Ja, ja.
Zack.
Na, gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub,
auf Shithub so trendet.
Deskflow.
Muss ich das eigentlich jedes Mal starten?
Resource Deadlock would occur.
Ja, wie? Was?
Sollen sie mal...
Sollen sie mal occur, der Resource Deadlock.
Tastatur schnell umstöpseln
Massive geheimes Passwort eingeben
Chat nicht hingucken jetzt
Guckt ihr weg
Ich will nicht, dass ihr das Passwort seht
Alle weggucken, okay
Ich tipp einfach schnell
Ich tipp einfach schneller, als dass ihr es seht
Damn, ihr habt es nicht gesehen
Das wird jetzt immer...
Den gucke ich übrigens auch manchmal.
Weil er so oldschool Super Nintendo Spiele spielt, die ich früher auch gespielt habe.
Also, spied dran.
Ah ja.
So, da sind wir.
Woher weißt du das, Meistertyp-Kit, dass ich da auch manchmal gucke?
Ich hab mich im Chat gesehen.
Wir wollen uns nicht bei Gwen einloggen.
So, jetzt ganz wichtig, erstmal Update.
Update und dann Reboot.
Ja, den Sieg auf meiner Weltrekordrun hab ich gesehen.
Aber erst danach.
Aha.
Wird über Chaterino gestalkt.
Das war ja auch mal
schlachten.
So, dann updaten wir erstmal alles.
Gibt es denn hier neue Sachen?
Oho, Updates sind am Start, Leute.
Äh, hallo?
Was auch immer.
So.
Übrigens, es gibt Neuigkeiten von der Arbeit, Leute.
Ich hab meine neue VM.
Die VM mit Grafikkarte drin und sowas.
Das ist gar nicht mal übel.
Also, vielleicht um euch da jetzt nochmal...
Wie sagt man businessmäßig so schön?
Um euch da jetzt mal aufzukleisen.
Chat, soll ich euch aufgleisen?
Es gibt so viele bescheuerte Redewendungen.
Um euch aufzugleisen und abzuholen, genau.
Ja, ja, genau, ich nehme euch in den Loop.
Aufgleisen klingt so weird.
Was ich übrigens auch super weird finde,
die Leute, die so businessmäßig reden,
die nicht sagen, wir testen das oder wir erproben das,
sondern die immer sagen, verproben.
So als hätten die jetzt irgendwie eine Speichelprobe genommen oder so.
Ich sag doch auch nicht, heute verproben wir Rust Rover.
Sag ich, hey, lass das mal testen, lass das mal ausprobieren.
Ja, verproben klingt nach
Gentest oder so
Also Chat, um euch
Aufzukleisen, ja
Bevor wir dann
Unser Daily Stand-Up machen
Also, es ist so
Ich krieg auf der Arbeit an Hardware
Nur Windows
Es gibt nichts anderes, das ist Vorschrift
Ich krieg ein Notebook von der Arbeit
Da ist Windows drauf
Und wenn ich
von daheim arbeite, habe ich die Möglichkeit
oder sagen wir mal so, egal ob ich
auch wenn ich aus dem Büro arbeite,
ja,
also wenn ich in die Versicherung fahre
und dort
mein Notebook anschließe
und so, ich habe zwei Möglichkeiten zu arbeiten.
Beides mit Windows. Das erste ist
per VPN
vom
Notebook aus oder halt
Notebook direkt ans
Netzwerk stecken
auf der Arbeit.
Und das zweite ist, per Browser auf Zytrix, also auf so ein Zytrix-Portal, mich dort einloggen und eine Windows-Zytrix-Kiste bekommen mit, wie nennt sich das?
Zytrix Viewer? Ne, Zytrix Workspaces heißt das, gell? Das neue. Ich glaube Workspaces, falls jemand von euch sich damit auskennt.
die zwei sachen habe ich also es ist egal was du machst es ist immer windows
es ist entweder windows auf dem notebook oder es ist oder es ist windows auf der
citrix kiste
citrix workspace ja ich glaube ich glaube das ist das so genau gucke ich mir das
anders geht einfach auf wenn ich das anklicke wobei wir können doch einfach
mal gucken. Ich hab diesen Mist
hier doch installiert. Wartet mal.
Task Manager.
Tasks.
Citrix, guck mal da.
Citrix Workspace. Da ist es doch.
Seht ihr es? Da ist es.
Citrix Workspace.
So. Ups.
Jetzt hab ich mich hier vertippt.
So.
Jetzt kann man
rebooten.
So.
Zumindest ist es jetzt so, ich habe jetzt zwei neue VMs beantragt.
Und die habe ich mittlerweile auch.
Ich habe einmal eine neue Zytrix-VM beantragt.
Mit Grafikkarte und allem möglichen Zeug drin.
Einfach, dass das Zytrix-Zeug an sich schneller ist.
So.
Weil das war schon...
Also wir haben die Auswahl, du kannst entweder den normalen...
Was ist denn da unter der Haube, Chat?
Terminal-Server-Windows?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Also du kannst die normalen Zytrix-VMs verwenden.
Manch einer würde sagen Shitrix-VMs.
Oder du kannst dir so eine Dedicated-VM holen.
Die hat dann sogar eine Grafikkarte weitergeleitet drin und sowas.
Also die kosten dann auch ein bisschen mehr.
Die musst du dir aber extra beantragen.
Dein Chef muss die genehmigen.
Das Zytrix-Team muss die genehmigen und so.
Das ist ein bisschen größer.
Dafür hast du dann auch ein bisschen mehr Performance.
So, das habe ich beantragt. Man muss sagen, der Unterschied zwischen der normalen Zytrix VM und dieser Dedicated Ressourcen Zytrix VM hält sich jetzt in Grenzen, aber es ist ein bisschen schneller.
Okay, ein bisschen weniger laggy.
Man kann das auf jeden Fall benutzen.
Ja, das ist...
Also es gibt...
Es ist natürlich nicht so snappy, wie wenn ich jetzt hier drücke und bam, alles ist sofort.
Ja, also ein bisschen lagg merkst du schon.
Du merkst schon den Unterschied zwischen 240 FPS Terminal versus Citrix Windows Gedöns.
Ja, das merkst du schon.
So, und jetzt habe ich noch eine zweite VM mit Linux drauf.
Die ist nicht übel.
Die hat eine 8-Kern-CPU, 16 Threads, 32 GB RAM, 200 GB SSD.
Also es ist auch eine ordentliche VM.
Und jetzt ist mein aktueller Workflow, an den ich mich versuche so ein bisschen zu gewöhnen ist.
Langt auch dicke zum Arbeiten.
Das Ding ist gar nicht so sehr die Hardware-Ausstattung.
Ey, Leute, bei mir steht dran, Drops aktiviert.
Welche Drops sind denn bei mir aktiviert?
Warum steht bei mir Drops aktiviert?
Was droppt bei mir, Chat?
Mir ist nicht bewusst, dass hier irgendwas droppt.
Was droppe ich denn?
Weil du in Just Chatting bist, Pokémon.
Okay.
IQ droppt.
Ja, das stimmt. Zu wenig Subscriptions heute und zu wenig Follows.
Da droppt der IQ.
Also Leute, ich habe mir das überlegt.
Es gibt jetzt nicht nur extra IQ-Punkte für jeden Subscription.
Es gibt auch einen halben IQ-Punkt für jeden Follow.
Also das heißt, Follow lohnt sich jetzt auch.
Hat sich natürlich vorher auch schon gelohnt.
weil man immer direkt informiert wird, wenn der Stream live geht.
Also, Followern ist an sich immer eine gute Idee.
Und außerdem, jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft, freue ich mich natürlich auch über jeden Follow,
weil Stonks,
alle, die nach oben zeigen,
sind immer gut.
Und ich freue mich immer, wenn mehr Leute gucken.
Und außerdem, und das ist auch ein bisschen seltsam,
nachdem ich in letzter Zeit so wenig streame,
Ich habe in den letzten Wochen nur einmal die Woche gestreamt.
Da kniert natürlich auch ein wenig die Followerzahl.
Was ja irgendwie auch nachvollziehbar ist.
Aber trotzdem, wenn euch der Stream gefällt, ich würde mich sehr freuen über einen Follow.
Zumindest, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also, ist die Citrix VM voreingestellt?
Was für eine Distribution verwendest du?
Also, ja, ich habe Sudo auf der VM.
Also, die Citrix VM ist Windows. Dann habe ich eine Linux VM mit Ubuntu drauf, die läuft irgendwo bei Google in der Cloud, glaube ich.
und auf die connecte ich mich dann per rdp über citrix das heißt ich weiß es klingt abenteuerlich
aber es die einzige variante gescheit zu arbeiten also das heißt im endeffekt mein es sieht also
wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich von daheim arbeit sieht das so aus ja home pc zu tricks zu tricks
RDP auf
Citrix
Windows VM
RDP auf Linux VM
Okay
So sieht das aus
Und ich kann es kaum glauben
Leute
Das funktioniert halbwegs
Das geht
Das ist ein bisschen laggy
Ja
Ja, also es ist nicht 240 Hertz Terminal wie hier, beziehungsweise 240 FPS Terminal wie hier, aber das geht.
Also ich hätte mir das deutlich schlimmer vorgestellt.
Und der große Vorteil davon ist, ich muss mich halt null mit Windows rumschlagen.
Ich habe das jetzt so gemacht, guckt, also stellt euch vor,
stellt euch vor, das hier wäre jetzt meine Zytrix-Kiste oder so, ja.
Oder nee, sag mal so.
Stellt euch vor, wir haben es doch hier.
Stellt euch vor, das hier wäre meine Zytrix-Kiste, okay?
So, Zytrix.
Jetzt gehe ich auf die Zytrix-Kiste rüber.
Und dann von hier quasi per RDP auf meine Linux-Kiste.
Genau.
So.
Und das geht.
Man hätte nicht...
Kann man den Zytrix-Windows-Teil nicht überspringen?
Nein.
Wir kriegen offiziell nur Windows-Kisten, weil die...
Nur die...
Ich weiß, klingt jetzt erstmal witzig, ja. Nur die richtig abgesichert werden können.
Aber Leute, wenn ihr in der Finanzbranche arbeitet, geht das nicht unbedingt immer um Realismus, sondern es gibt Vorgaben, was für Software zur Sicherheit da drauf installiert sein muss und die gibt es halt nur für Windows.
Was ich für RDP benutze
Von Windows aus
Von Windows benutze ich den ganz normalen MSTSC
Auf Linux benutze ich
XRDP
Ich bin auch auf X11
Ich hab's mit Wayland probiert, Leute
Ich hab's mit Wayland probiert
Du kannst ja im Endeffekt nur Gnome installieren
Mit Wayland, aktuell
Also das
Gnome ist der einzige größere Desktop, der RDP ordentlich supportet.
KDE geht nur mit eingeloggt, das Session und sowas, kannst du klicken.
Und der verschluckt Shortcuts, wie es gerade einer im Chat schon geschrieben hat, das kannst du nicht benutzen.
Was aber echt erstaunlich gut funktioniert ist, XRDP.
Ich habe einen Ubuntu auf der VM.
Da ist ein XRDP drauf.
und das einzige, was ich an diesem XRDP
noch umkonfiguriere ist,
was da standardmäßig für ein Encoding
für die Bilder benutzt,
aber das ist echt in Ordnung. Und der
große Vorteil ist für mich,
ich hab das jetzt so geregelt,
also ich hab hier meinen Citrix im
Fullscreen und da drin
hab ich direkt mein RDP im Fullscreen.
Das heißt, ich sitze im Endeffekt
bei mir auf der Arbeit vom Monitor
mit einem Linux Desktop.
So wie hier. Nur, dass
es in XFCE ist, weil ich was leichtgewichtiges
haben wollte.
Ich habe eine Linux-Desktop
bei mir auf der Arbeit. Fullscreen.
So, ich habe sogar Teams
unter Linux laufen.
Ich kann mich
einloggen auf allen möglichen Servern
über unseren SSH-Proxy, von da
ich habe mir die
wichtigsten Sachen per SSH-Port
Weiterleitung weitergeleitet.
Also ich muss jetzt eigentlich nur noch
in Windows
für zwei Sachen.
Wenn ich Outlook machen,
wenn ich irgendwas in Outlook machen will,
was nur mit dem Desktop-Client geht,
das ist glücklicherweise sehr selten.
Oder wenn ich
irgendwelche internen Services
brauche, die nicht
erreichbar sind von
der Linux-VM.
Aber selbst da könnte ich tricksen
mit noch ein paar SSH-Portfiter-Leitungen.
Also ich brauche, ich brauche, doch, es gibt eine Sache, es gibt eine Sache, wofür ich tatsächlich Windows und Teams noch brauche und das ist, mein Teams auf der Arbeit zeigt nur unter Windows an, dass ich Calls switchen kann.
Kennt ihr das? Wenn man einen Teams Call am Handy annimmt und am Desktop Teams aufmacht, dann kannst du am Desktop klicken, ich will den Call jetzt übernehmen. Oder du kannst auch sagen, ich will dieses Gerät dem Call hinzufügen.
Das geht bei mir nur, wenn ich es auf meinem Notebook Teams unter Windows mache. Das geht nicht im Citrix Teams und das geht auch nicht im Browser Teams unter Linux. Keine Ahnung, warum das der Fall ist. Microsoft Logik, fragt mich nicht.
das heißt wenn ich screen sharen will und mit dem handy telefonieren will also desktop screen
dann muss ich das muss ich noch kurz auf windows wischen aber ansonsten das kommt jetzt ja auch
nicht laufen vor ansonsten easy habe ich hier auch auf der arbeit linux im fullscreen einziger
unterschied was ich an terminal habe ist ich benutze nicht west haben sondern terminator
aber mit den gleichen short cuts also es hält sich hält sich dann auch in grenzen der unterschied und
halt anstatt ein KDE, ein XFCE.
Aber im Prinzip sieht fast genauso aus
wie hier. Fullscreen-Browser,
Fullscreen-Dings, hier Fullscreen-Editor
und sonst was.
Ja, Kitty,
da bin ich nicht so scharf drauf,
weil der Kitty-Autor so gegen
Temux ist. Und ich bin ja großer
Temux-Fan auf dem Server.
Also ich hab auf fast jedem Server,
auf dem ich mich einlogge und da ein bisschen
was mache, was länger als
fünf Minuten dauert, habe ich erstmal eine
Temux-Session gestartet. Und der
Kitty-Autor sagt ja explizit,
Temux ist ein Anti-Pattern aus seiner
Sicht. Keine Ahnung,
warum das so ist,
aber auf Servern Temux
ist schon sehr sinnvoll,
gerade wenn man sich mit anderen Leuten eine Session
sharen will und sowas.
Hast du eigentlich mitbekommen,
dass die Daten von Berlin jetzt im Darknet
veröffentlicht wurden? Ja, habe ich mitbekommen.
Da sind so Sachen drin wie,
Ich glaube, Arbeitszeugnisse, Urlaubsplanungen, wer wie viel Gehalt bekommt, irgendwelche Ausweiskopien und alles mögliche.
Die Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, ist, also um euch jetzt nochmal kurz aufzugleisen.
Berlin hat ja einen
Hackerangriff erlebt
und zwar haben die so gut wie alle Daten abgezogen
aus der Verwaltung
oder viele Daten aus der Verwaltung abgezogen
und haben gedroht, haben quasi
Berlin erpresst
sie veröffentlichen die Daten
und Berlin hat gesagt
da lassen wir uns gar nicht drauf ein
wir bezahlen kein Lösegeld
was ich mich jetzt halt
Was ich mich jetzt halt frage ist, hätte man den Leak abwenden können, dadurch, dass man Lösegeld bezahlt hat?
Weil die Erpresser haben ja durchaus ein gewisses Interesse dran, es nicht zu leaken, nachdem sie ein Lösegeld bekommen haben.
Wenn sie das nächste Mal wieder Lösegeld verlangen wollen.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Also wenn die Berlin-Erpresser, wenn die quasi Lösegeld kassiert hätten und hätten direkt die Daten geleakt, dann würde das nächste Mal definitiv niemand mehr Lösegeld bezahlen.
Also man weiß jetzt nicht, wie zukunftsorientiert die sind.
Auf der anderen Seite, wie viel? 2,5 Millionen oder so in Bitcoin ist halt schon eine ordentliche Stange Geld.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die sich da auf das Experiment hätten eingelassen.
Ich frage mich halt, hätte es in dem Fall was gebracht, das Lösegeld zu bezahlen?
Kann man so und so sehen.
Eine Garantie gibt es nicht.
Aber du musst doch auch zugeben, dass die Erpresser, wenn sie in Zukunft quasi unter gleichem Namen nochmal auftreten wollen und nochmal Lösegeld verlangen wollen,
dass sie ein gewisses Interesse in eine, sagen wir mal, halbwegs Glaubwürdigkeit haben,
dass sie es nicht veröffentlichen, weil ansonsten wird definitiv niemand mehr Lösegeld bezahlen bei denen.
Also nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen, dass sie ein gewisses Interesse daran haben, wenn die damit weitermachen wollen.
Das weißt du bei der Stadt Berlin aber eh, dass da was zu holen ist.
Ja, das ist ein Fehler. Das ist unabhängig davon ein Fehler, diese gleichen Systeme wieder eins zu eins ans Netz zu bringen.
Wobei ich in dem Fall auch nicht glaube, dass sie das gemacht haben.
Aber es ist halt schon wieder lächerlich. Ich habe eine Liste gesehen.
Ich habe eine Liste gesehen auf Twitter.
X, formerly known as Twitter.
Mit Passwörtern von der Berliner Verwaltung.
Und es war sinngemäß Amsterdam123 war das Passwort bei vielen Sachen.
Oder 1amsterdam23.
Krasses Passwort, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das im Stream zeigen darf.
Und die Passwörter waren wirklich lächerlich.
Ja, das war ja anscheinend von vielen Systemen nicht erlaubt.
Die haben schon die Passwortrichtlinien.
Also, die Passwortrichtlinien waren dann halt mindestens eine Zahl, mindestens ein Großbuchstabe, mindestens so und so lang und mindestens ein Sonderzeichen.
Und daraus haben die dann halt gemacht, okay, mindestens eine Zahl, mindestens groß.
Dann haben die dann halt gemacht, Amsterdam, 1, 2, 3 Ausrufezeichen.
Dann hast du quasi alles erfüllt.
Das ist aber halt trotzdem kein super schwer zu gessendes Passwort.
Es ist an vielen Stellen so.
Ich will gar nicht wissen, wie viele Leute bei uns auf der Arbeit
für irgendwelche Accounts solche Passwörter haben.
Und glücklicherweise, wenn du bei uns Homeoffice dich einloggen willst,
über Citrix, dann brauchst du mehr als nur dein Passwort.
Also du brauchst Account, Passwort und auch mehrere zusätzliche Authentifizierungstokens.
Weil ich könnte wetten, da gibt es auch übliche Verdächtige, die die Passwort haben dann irgendwie Frankfurt123 underscore oder sowas.
Könnte ich wetten, dass es genug so Leute gibt in der Richtung.
So, habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet? Ja, ne? Habe ich gemacht.
Update lief.
Excellent.
Hier nochmal Update.
Warum squatters eigentlich meine Mirrors?
Das würde doch reichen, wenn er das komplett
einmal im Monat macht, nicht jedes Mal.
Ich habe auch schon Leute bei uns gesehen
mit dem Klassiker
Passwort TXT.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, es ist wahrscheinlich besser, die Leute würden Passwörter auf einen Zettel schreiben,
anstatt sich eine Passwort-TXT auf dem Desktop hinzuhauen.
hinzuhauen weil da hast du immer noch so dass das ganze noch wie man so schön sagt er gibt
also irgendein angreifer der auf dem desktop pc das sekretärin gelandet ist weil sie irgendwelche
excel makros ausgeführt hat kommt easy an die passwort txt dran der kommen aber nicht so easy
an den zettel dran wo das passwort draufsteht top beste max was also wir
haben den kieper bei uns auf der arbeit dann kieper safe mit dem echt langen
passwort das also unser pack unsere passwort logik ist wir haben uns ein
übelst bescheuerten Satz ausgedacht.
So,
Wubblords Twitch Chat Beste.
Und
den haben wir als Passwort genommen.
Plus noch ein Sonderzeichen.
Oder ein paar Sonderzeichen drin sogar.
In der Mitte ist ein Sonderzeichen, am Ende ist noch ein Sonderzeichen.
Irgendwo dazwischen ist auch noch ein Sonderzeichen.
Und der liegt auch shared.
Der Keypass Passwort Self,
der liegt auch shared auf irgendeinem...
Windows-Laufwerk rum.
Aber solange KeyPass,
gehen wir mal von aus, dass KeyPass soweit sicher ist,
passiert da nichts.
Max, was ist eigentlich deine Meinung zu Metabrillen?
Sollten die der Öffentlichkeit verboten werden?
Also ich sehe das Problem,
wenn einer den ganzen Tag quasi mit einer Kamera rumläuft, die andere Leute filmen könnte oder filmt.
Vieles geht da mit dem Handy heute auch schon, nur dass das halt offensichtlicher ist.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich finde es in der Regel erstmal nicht gut, immer neue Sachen direkt zu regulieren und zu verbieten.
Vielleicht müsste man in der heutigen Zeit, also ich finde das nicht gut, permanent andere Leute zu filmen, ja.
Aber vielleicht müsste man in der heutigen Zeit einfach mal gucken, wird das überhaupt zu unbehagen bei den Leuten.
Weil die Leute sind heute so, YOLO, Datenschutz ist mir scheißegal, dass das wahrscheinlich gar keinen mehr juckt, wenn sie den ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchen Metabrillen gefilmt werden.
Also mich würde das tatsächlich schon jucken.
Aber ich glaube,
ein Großteil der Bevölkerung juckt das nicht.
Müssen wir mal gucken,
wie da so der allgemeine
Konsens ist.
Ob die das wollen oder nicht.
Warum sollte das Frauen mehr jucken als Männer, wenn sie irgendwie in der Fußgängerzone in der Masse von Leuten da mit gefilmt werden?
Ich meine, die filmen ja nicht explizit einzelne Leute, die filmen halt explizit, während sie draußen rumlaufen.
Wäre das natürlich...
Okay, das kann natürlich schon, sagen wir mal, genutzt werden, um Persönlichkeitsrechte verletzende Aufnahmen zu machen.
Ja, so von wegen Ausschnittfilm und sowas.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja wahrscheinlich mit einer Brille auch recht auffällig, ja.
Also es ist schwierig.
Also ich finde es in der Regel nicht gut, so Sachen immer direkt zu regulieren und zu verbieten.
Ich sehe das aber auch kritisch mit Kameras.
Da müsste man einfach wirklich mal gucken, wie viele Leute das wirklich juckt.
Also mich, ich würde es nicht wollen.
Also ich hätte keinen Bock darauf gefilmt zu werden, irgendwo, wenn ich da unterwegs bin.
Aber ich bin mir in der heutigen Zeit nicht sicher, ob es wirklich so viele juckt.
Theoretisch, by the way, das ist tatsächlich sogar verboten, ja.
Aber es ist halt schwierig, das festzustellen mit solchen Brillen.
Ich glaube, du darfst, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie das ist, du darfst Menschenmengen filmen,
aber sobald irgendwie quasi einzelne Leute daraus hervorstechen oder so, ist das glaube ich verboten.
Ja, aber Chat, wir sind hier auch nicht repräsentativ.
Wir sind hier IT-Kellerkinder, die sich für Security und Privatsphäre interessieren.
Dafür interessieren sich die 99% der Weltbevölkerung nicht.
So, machen wir den ganzen Krebbel hier mal zu.
Okay.
Ja, also Sprachaufnahmen in Teams, ohne dass man es mitbekommt, finde ich auch kacke.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch laut Policy in den meisten Unternehmen nicht erlaubt,
ob das Sprachaufnahmen oder
gar komplette Callaufnahmen. Ich meine, ich könnte
ja auch jederzeit, wenn ich Homeoffice mache,
könnte ich OBS starten und aufnehmen.
Komplett.
Aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das bei uns
durch irgendwelche Policies
verboten ist. Mach ich auch nicht.
Macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Aber das finde ich auch immer
kacke, wenn da irgendwas aufgenommen wird.
Selbst wenn man zieht.
Du wirst im Zweifelsfall
noch konfrontiert, zwei Monate
später, dass du gesagt hast, nächste Woche ist es fertig.
Gibt es unter Windows
eigentlich einen Waff-Recorder?
Ja, gab es hier nicht Memos oder wie das heißt?
Oder Sound? Sound-Recorder-App.
Was?
Sound-Recorder-App needs an update.
Okay, den alten gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr.
WTF?
Alter.
Was ist das?
Das ist Audacity für arme Leute
Äh
Yes, okay, okay
Okay, okay
Okay, funktioniert
Und das kann man jetzt speichern als
Äh, wie speichert man das überhaupt?
Show in folder
Ah, das ist schon
Das ist schon gespeichert
Ja, Audacity 4
habe ich gesehen
Okay, ja, also das ist anscheinend der neue Wafferecorder
Naja
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie
Audacity für Arme
Audacity 4
habe ich mir gestern im Video zu angeguckt
Sieht jetzt voll modern aus
Äh
Wait a minute, muss erst mal
So, schauen wir mal, was trendet denn auf GitHub so?
Die Mehrheit juckt es nicht, bis es halt zu spät ist.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt schon.
Das sieht man ja auch an der ganzen Diskussion jetzt wieder um Massenüberwachung.
Und Chatkontrolle und sonst was.
Die meisten Leute haben da überhaupt keinen Bezug zu.
Ja, das ist ja mittlerweile die Standardantwort für alles.
Wenn irgendwas eingeführt werden muss, wird zuerst gesagt, man macht das zum Schutz der Kinder. Danach wird gesagt, man macht das zum Schutz vor Terroristen. Danach wird gesagt, man macht das zum Schutz vor schweren Verbrechen wie Mord und so oder zum Aufklären von Mord. Und das wird dann immer weiter verwässert.
irgendwann geht es dann auch für Steuerhinterziehung, für Urheberrechtsprobleme und irgendwann für jeden Scheiß.
Das sind wir ja schon gewohnt, dass das so passiert.
So, also lass mal gucken, was trendet denn diese Woche, nicht today, this week.
Wir gucken mal diese Woche und diesen Monat, schauen wir mal.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich AI, AI, AI, AI.
Ja, ja, das ist genau, Chad.
Das ist das nächste hier.
Und sobald das dann etabliert ist, irgendwann wird das immer weiter ausgeweitet, immer weiter ausgeweitet, dann geht es für Urheberrechtsgeschichte und irgendwann sind wir dann angelangt, wenn irgendwie einer auf Twitter was Falsches sagt, zählt das auch darunter.
Okay.
Also, was trendet denn?
Gucken wir mal.
Archify.
AI.
ich bin nicht mehr durch open court open court open code oder whatever
so die schreiben hier die schreiben hier open source coding agent cli ich dachte ich dachte
Die coolen Leute nennen das heutzutage Harness.
Wenn du da unabhängig quasi
Sachen von laufen lassen kannst.
So ein bisschen Sandbox.
Ich blicke da nicht mehr durch.
Wie gesagt, es vergeht kein Tag,
wo nicht drei neue Sachen spawnen.
AI?
Keine Ahnung, was es ist,
aber es sieht nicht nach AI aus.
cute logo dachte harnes harnes ist vor allem halt ein bisschen sandbox drumherum so verstehe
ich das zumindest ja da kannst du dann quasi mehrere agents unabhängig an unterschiedlichen
aufgaben unterschiedlich teilen von einem projekt unterschiedlich projekt arbeiten lassen
also ist dann quasi open cloud ein agent den du in einem harnis laufen ist tail cat ist
bild und tail cat wie ach nee und was macht es open source ist so ecklein netcat but over
Tailscale. Also man kann
Netketten
über Tailscale. Okay, wenn man
Tailscale verwendet, ist das bestimmt sehr praktisch.
AI?
Absolut keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Es ist in Swift, also es ist irgendwas für Apple.
AI?
Virtual iPhone via Apples Virtualization Frameworks
Äh
Aha
Es muss natürlich ein Mac sein
Logischerweise
FMT
FMT-Lib trendet
Warum haben die ein neues Release oder was
Also FMT-Lib ist legit der einzige Weg
Strings sinnvoll zu formatieren
In C++
Ein Teil von FMT-Lib ist ja seit C++23, glaube ich, auch in der Standard-Library gelandet.
Trotzdem kann FMT-Lib noch mehr.
Das heißt ja sogar gar nicht unsinnig, das zusätzlich zu verwenden.
Warum hat es diese Woche ausgerechnet 1800?
Aber ich finde, die sind trotzdem ein bisschen hinten dran.
Guckt mal.
Die haben immer noch dieses Formatting hier.
Wisst ihr, ich muss euch ja ehrlich sagen
So cool
So cool dieses Formatding
Hier ist, ne
Hier ist
Wäre es nicht viel besser
Achso, warte mal
Wir sind in C++
Wäre es nicht viel besser
Man könnte einfach
sowas machen?
Oder, keine Ahnung.
Sowas?
Wäre doch viel, viel angenehmer, oder nicht?
Das geht in Rust mittlerweile sogar halbwegs
mit dem Format Makro.
Nicht so schön wie in C Sharp,
aber halbwegs.
Und wisst ihr was?
Eigentlich
wäre das doch
in C++
auch ganz gut möglich.
Die machen so viele
Preprocessor und Compiler
Rewrite Magic, dass sie
sowas auch einbauen
könnten.
Ja, aber es gibt in, wir gucken mal,
es gibt glaube ich C++
String Interpolation.
String Interpolation gibt es nicht.
Vielleicht wird das mit C++26
möglich. Wirklich? Gibt es da was Neues?
Durch Reflection.
Oh, wie soll Reflection
denn da helfen?
Ja, doch.
Reflection könnte da tatsächlich helfen.
Als das irgendwie geht,
du müsstest dann quasi
den String scannen
nach
Variablen
und dann irgendwie per Reflection,
falls das überhaupt geht,
die Variable suchen.
Boah, ich glaube, das geht nicht.
Ich glaube, das geht nicht.
Ja, siehst du, das ist das Funs nicht.
Ich meine sowas wie
Template String Interpolation.
Okay.
In C++ gibt es keine Native Syntax.
Aber modernes C++...
Ja, laber nicht!
Das weiß ich, dass das geht.
Eine kleine...
Du müsstest dir selbst eine kleine Interpolationsfunktion bauen.
Ja, erkläre mal, wie das funktionieren soll.
Und das soll funktionieren.
Wie sollen das funktionieren?
Woher soll diese Funktion, was labert ChatGPT da?
Woher soll diese Funktion bitte schön wissen, dass es diese Variable gibt überhaupt?
Okay, hier gibt es sogar ein Beispiel für.
Ja, geil. Ja, geil.
Interpolate String Variable.
Ja.
Ja, oh, geil. Ja, das bringt es.
Ja, das ist natürlich...
Das ist natürlich genau das, was ich
hab mit Chat-KBD.
Alter, was ein Bullshit, man.
Hardrate-Monitor, ja.
Bist du dumm?
Was C++ angeht
Was?
Safety Reason
Wie jetzt?
Bist du dumm?
Okay, bist du dumm?
Vielleicht beleidigt er mich ja gerade.
Und deswegen.
Was wolltest du sagen?
Heck weh.
Oh, wir haben Chat-GPT hart getriggert.
Jetzt reg dich mal ab.
Oh, Chat.
Wir haben es geprokt.
Das ist kaputt.
P, was?
P3412.
Okay.
Uh.
Ja, Moment.
Aber das ist in C++23 noch gar nicht drin.
Weil C++26.
Weil C++26 ist doch...
Ist doch abgeschlossen mittlerweile, oder?
Und nicht in 26 drinne.
Oder doch?
Ja, das wäre top.
Das wäre richtig gut, wenn das geht.
Ja, erstmal 50 Seiten.
Alter, guck mal, C++,
MonKS, 30 Seiten,
erstmal 30 Seiten
Paper darüber geschrieben.
Okay, Klang, kann das?
Leute, sprecht ihr das Klang
oder C-Lang aus? Ich tendiere ja
zu C-Lang, aber ich glaube offiziell
spricht man das Klang aus.
Okay, das ist cool, wenn das geht.
Interpolation.
Simplicity.
C++. Simplicity.
Dazu muss ich ja schon eher sagen.
C++ Simplicity, alles ist klar.
Ja, das gab mal einen Patch.
Es gab da wohl einen Patch.
Ob das natürlich jetzt in Stable dann auch reinkommt, ist halt die Frage.
müssen wir mal kurz gucken
ist
in C++
26 drin
nein
tja
fuck
Das wäre schon echt nice.
Das würde die Sprache mal deutlich besser machen.
Aber seit wann baut das C++-Gremium denn irgendwas ein, was die Sprache deutlich besser macht?
Chat, wo kämen wir denn da hin?
Wenn die Sprache mit neuen Standards besser werden würde.
Das geht ja nicht.
Da muss man eher sowas hier einbauen.
Da muss man eher so sehr schön lesbare Dinge einbauen.
Sowas hier.
Oh, ist das nicht geil lesbar, Leute?
Alter, ist das...
Chefskiss, Alter.
Obviously, was das macht, oder?
Ist das nicht super krass toll lesbar?
Oh ja, das hier ist noch besser.
Guck mal, das ist noch viel besser lesbar.
Ich sag's euch, bald ist es so,
dass eine Random-Anordnung
von Text
mit Sonderzeichen
drin ist. Das ist gültiges
C++ in ein paar Standards.
Einmal Face Roll.
Kann GCC das denn?
GCC Compiler Explorer.
Aha. Und was kann man da...
Wo kann man hier...
In Suchfeld? Ne, Suchfeld gibt es natürlich nicht.
Warte mal, kann SIG...
Kann SIG das?
Das wäre ja witzig.
Okay, das kann nur...
Klang.
Suchen wir nicht Standard...
Nee.
Nee, suchen wir nicht.
Guck mal.
Ich will...
Okay, das Beispiel ist vielleicht nicht so geil.
Ich hätte gerne...
Wir machen das Beispiel mal ein bisschen anders, okay?
Wir formatieren das mal so.
Weil ansonsten ist es schwierig.
Ich würde gerne so schreiben können.
Guck mal.
Anstatt das hier...
Würde ich gerne sowas hier schreiben können.
Wäre das nicht viel nicer?
Meinetwegen auch irgendwie...
Wie ist es in Python? So? F?
Weiß ich nicht. Oder JavaScript.
JavaScript ist es so.
Ja, das wäre auch okay.
Wäre das nicht viel nicer?
so zu schreiben,
anstatt so.
Ich find das viel schöner.
Das würde die Sprache auch viel besser lesbar machen.
So zur Abwechslung mal.
Und ich noch wirrer.
Okay, dann fragen wir doch noch mal.
Will
B in C++ 26.
If you mean
Not in C++26
Okay, das heißt wir sehen uns in C++29
Wenn wir Glück haben
Tell me
Ja, das wissen wir schon
Okay
Also anscheinend nicht
Habt ihr das da gesehen, by the way?
Was ist das denn wieder für
Alter, was ist das denn wieder für
Absolut abscheuliches
Diese Syntax, man
Was denken die sich denn eigentlich?
Also gucken wir mal weiter
FMT-Lip trendet
meiner Meinung nach vollkommen zu Recht
FNT-Lib ist der einzig
erträgliche Weg, Strings in C++
zu formatieren.
Hi, wie gibt man da Formatparameter
an? Ja, da müssen Sie sich eine Syntax
für ausdenken.
Einfach Doppelpunkt.
Ich glaube, in Rust machst du einfach
einen Doppelpunkt an der Stelle dann.
Ja, da müssen Sie sich irgendwas ausdenken,
wie man das macht.
Man könnte
ja auch sowas hier machen.
Keine Ahnung, so.
So, blablublublub.
Irgendwie sowas.
Jetzt hier Variable.
Und dann sagst du Doppelpunkt dahinter.
Doppelpunkt
Punkt 2F oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich glaube, so ähnlich macht es Go.
Ich glaube, in Go
ist es so. So oder so ähnlich.
Ja, gibt es ja mehrere
Möglichkeiten, wie man das machen kann.
Da müssen sie sich irgendwas ausdenken.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier zu bieten?
China-Chinesen-Ding.
Keine Ahnung.
Skill ist eindeutig KI.
Rollstudio, KI.
AI.
Höchstwahrscheinlich auch AI.
A spy satellite simulator in your browser.
Accept the data is real.
Okay.
Wir zoomen mal Frankfurt.
Wir zoomen mal Frankfurt ran.
Was?
Ich will nicht subscriben.
Äh.
Und wo kann man das jetzt benutzen?
Gar nicht, oder?
Ich check's nicht
Und wie benutzt man das jetzt?
Muss man das selbst hosten, oder was?
Das klingt aber echt ganz cool.
Pinocchio.
Was bin ich?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Universal One-Click-Launcher
Das ist sowas wie
Wie Flatpak?
Nur in nicht Flatpak oder was?
Warum braucht KI
sein eigenes Flatpack.
Muss man nicht wirklich verstehen, oder?
Okay, das ist mir zu high IQ.
Das gucke ich mir irgendwann offline vielleicht mal an.
Wenn ihr das jetzt am Laufen habt,
dann braucht man eine halbe Stunde oder so.
So, was haben wir als nächstes noch?
MCP-Servers.
KI.
Ach ja.
Ein paar Tools
für
iOS-Anwendungen.
AI.
java code style checker und ei ok und jetzt schauen wir was diesen monat so getrennt hat
jetzt aber schnell drüber was haben wir sonst noch
AI?
Oh, Machi.
Monkei ist alter.
AI?
Vielleicht nicht AI?
Exzellent!
QuickMuffs!
Ja, deswegen habe ich doch aufgemacht, weil es nicht AI ist.
Aber ich muss sagen, es kommt selten vor, dass ich Mathe-Animationen erstellen möchte.
Aber es gibt bestimmt Leute, die wollen das.
Okay, gucken wir mal kurz schnell drüber, was bei den üblichen Verdächtigen...
Wir fangen mal hier mit Rast an.
Die Krustentiere.
Hyper-Efficient Message Streaming at Laser Speed.
Ernsthaft, Leute.
Wer denkt sich diese Projektbezeichnung immer aus?
Da kann sich doch keine Sau was drunter vorstellen.
Hyper Efficient...
Das ist sowas wie Rapid MQ oder was?
Oder was soll das sein?
Ist Laser Speed das neue Blazingly Fast?
Ich könnte fast wetten, die haben Laser Speed geschrieben, weil Blazingly Fast zu ausgelutscht ist.
Okay, was ist das genau?
Persistent Message Streaming Plattform
written in Rust.
Also im Prinzip sowas wie
RapidMQ.
Oder gibt es ja noch ein paar andere.
AMQP oder irgendwie so Zeug.
mit endpoints für quick websocket und http ok es ist es ist letztendlich so eine art message
kune würde ich mal sagen oder er eher ein reiner message broadcast fragezeichen weil sie nicht
aber es ist krass hyper speed weil blazing die fast dritten in rust
Ja.
Das ist echt ein Projekt, wo ich mir denken würde,
vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen griffigere Produktbezeichnung,
äh, nicht Produktbezeichnung,
Produktbeschreibung wäre nicht verkehrt.
Ja, ich gette, dass das irgendwie so,
ich muss ja mal sagen, so, so,
dass das interessant machen sollte,
aber ich lese das erstmal und denke mir so,
ey, was wollt ihr eigentlich genau von mir?
Und vor allem die längere Produktbeschreibung,
finde ich, also, also, weiß nicht,
Es ist so eine Art Message
Broadcast, Message Queue
Die aber hyper efficient ist
Und super schnell
Okay, Wifi
Wifi
Security Auditing Software
Okay
Firecracker 4Ms, das habe ich mir schon mal angeguckt
Das ist nix für mich
Wobei ich diese
Micro-Sandbox-Geschichte hier ganz gut finde
E-GUI
Also sowas wie
Im-GUI nur für Rust
Open Source
Loom Alternative
Beautiful Shareable Screen Recordings
Gibt es das auch für Linux?
No Cap.
Okay, es ist hübscher als OBS.
Das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Ja, okay, aber...
Gibt es hier Download?
Release es.
Komm, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal kurz an.
Was? API Key?
Ach, das ist ein Cloud-Service.
Das ist ein Cloud-Service.
Warum brauche ich denn einen Cloud-Service, um Videos bei mir lokal aufzuzeichnen?
Fragezeichen.
Tab.
Record.
sind ich ja okay keine ahnung ob man das braucht all versions gibt es auch so für linux irgendwie
es gibt so als demian package und hierbei release das war da irgendwas drin linux hier das gibt es
nur als demian package oder net ich meine ich könnte jetzt ich könnte jetzt irgendwie den
demian docker container starten und da irgendwie was
Wobei da hat er keinen zugriff auf einen server dann
wurscht
modern embedded framework using rust and async okay das ist quasi für
sp 32 fragezeichen unter anderem
Sp haus wird ja
Okay.
Was mich halt persönlich ein bisschen davon abhält,
also wir haben das mal ganz rudimentär,
haben wir mal auf dem ESP32 das ausprobiert mit Rust.
Was mich halt ein bisschen davon abhält ist,
dir fehlen halt die ganzen Device-Treiber und sowas.
Für Displays, Sensoren und sowas.
Für einige Verbreitete gibt es was,
aber ich glaube, du wirst mit Sicherheit für C++ quasi jedes noch so obskure Display was finden, aber in Rust nicht.
So, wie macht man das denn mit ESP32?
Die da mal eigentlich
Okay, wir machen mal
Ami, Example, ESP32
Zeigt mir mal was
Aber das von 2023
Ist äh
ok
phaeton phaeton excellente
Wir gucken mal was.
Acer.
Ethernet.
USB.
Okay.
Source.
Main.
Hallo.
Das sind ja angeblich 240 Lines.
Das sieht nicht aus wie 240 Lines.
GitHub.
Jetzt.
Oh, WTF?
What?
Okay, Rust ist teilweise
echt auch nicht so sonderlich schön zu lesen.
Aber es geht.
Oh.
Also ganz ehrlich,
ich würde wahrscheinlich bei dem offiziellen
C++ SDK bleiben, wenn ich
ESP32-Zeug bastle.
Skill AI
Awesome Rust, das ist so eine Liste mit
1000 Sachen, ne
Anki
Das gibt's immer, Moment, Anki, ist das jetzt
Written in Rust?
Das gibt's doch
Schon 20 Jahre oder so
Gibt's das nicht schon ewig?
Anki
Wir gehen jetzt mal da zurück
Ist es schon immer written in Rust?
Ne, ne ist es nicht
Ne
Python war das ursprünglich, genau
Genau
Weil ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, dass der
Anki Developer
Auch ein bisschen geflamed hat, dass es so schwierig ist
Python Programme zu distributen
Und wir reden jetzt nicht
Server Backends
im Docker-Container, sondern halt
Anwendungen für User.
Da hat er auch übelst rumgeflammt
in manchen GitHub-Issues.
Und jetzt hat er es
rewritten in Rust.
So.
AI.
Nee, nicht wirklich AI, aber
Text-Editor. AI.
Starship.
finde ich mega nice, dass Starship trendet.
Weil mein Prompt hier,
der da,
der ist auch,
der ist Starship.
Starship.
Habe ich da jetzt ein Binary bei mir rumliegen?
Ne, ich habe das installiert.
Ja, aber da hast du eine andere Shell als ich.
Mag es vielleicht unnötig sein,
aber hier ist es nicht unnötig.
Omniget
FFFF
Fastest and most accurate
File search SDK
For AI agents
Okay, whatever, KI
Delta, Delta benutze ich tatsächlich auch
In letzter Zeit öfters mal
Ja, gehen wir mal hier hin
und sagen jetzt, git log minus 1
minus p.
Geil.
Ach, guck, das ist Delta
hier, was mir meine git-diffs anzeigt.
Finde ich ein bisschen hübscher.
Ein bisschen schöner lesbar als das
normale git-diff.
Das finde ich auch okay. Ihr wisst ja,
ich benutze ungern
default-abweichende Sachen,
sofern man sie halt auch auf dem Server benutzt.
Aber Git benutzt du so gut wie nie auf dem Server, deswegen kann man sich das lokal schön konfigurieren.
Aber ihr wisst ja, ich bin Git-Fanboy, also Git-CLI-Fanboy.
Ich würde nie auf die Idee kommen, Git irgendwie über einen Editor oder über eine IDE zu benutzen.
Nur Git-CLI ist das einzig Wahre.
PNPM trendet.
Oh ja, PNPM wurde jetzt rewritten in Rust.
Also kein Witz, habe ich letztens ein Video gesehen auf YouTube.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist PNPM 12 jetzt rewritten in Rust.
Warum? Ich weiß es nicht.
Guck, ich kann es euch beweisen.
Also hier, guckt, das ist jetzt...
Guckt, PNPN 11, das alte, das ist noch rewritten in...
JavaScript wahrscheinlich?
Ja.
TypeScript.
Und das neue PNPM ist jetzt in Rust.
Ich habe allerdings die Vermutung,
dass das per
KI
zu Rust konvertiert wurde.
Wie Bann?
Ja, vielleicht.
Naja, wir können ja mal gerade reingucken.
Moment, jetzt bin ich ja verwirrt.
Wir können ja gerade mal reingucken, ob das nach AI-Written aussieht.
Wobei man das immer schwieriger erkennt.
CLI-Args
Wie viel Zeug? Test, geil, da ist einfach nichts drin.
Completion. Da ist halt einfach gar nichts drin.
Keine Ahnung. Ah, da ist bestimmt viel Vibe-Coded drin.
PN...
PM...
12...
Rust...
Rewrite...
Vibe-Coded...
Ich mein, solange es funktioniert, ist das ja eigentlich kein Ding, ne?
Also, wie gesagt, ich habe ein bisschen die Vermutung, dass es zum größten Teil automatisch per KI übersetzt.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich bin mir da auch unschlüssig, ob es so eine gute Idee ist, alle Programme in Rust zu rewriten.
Das macht jetzt vielleicht auf den ersten Blick erstmal Sinn.
Die Dinger sind danach schneller.
Aber ich behaupte einfach mal, für Leute, die nicht viel Rust-Erfahrung haben und auch für Leute, die viel Rust-Erfahrung haben,
Rust ist einfach unproduktiver als TypeScript, Python, C Sharp oder sonst was.
wenn du wenn du zwei leute nimmst die sich ähnlich gut auskennen ja du nimmst ein der sich
brauchbar auskennen in c sharp oder in go und du nimmst einer sich brauchbar auskennen rast
und die sollen das gleiche machen die leute die es in c sharp oder go machen sind einfach
schneller fertig beziehungsweise können der gleichen zeit mehr sachen einbauen
rast hat vielleicht andere vorteile in anderen bereichen ja aber für viele anwendungen ist das
gar nicht mal so sinnvoll.
Die Geschwindigkeit
von Go und C-Sharp sind mehr
als schnell genug.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass wenn es
3 Millisekunden braucht,
30% schneller ist, als es irgendwie
spürbar ändern würden.
Und die
Vorteile von Rust liegen halt
eindeutig drin.
Wenn du was haben willst,
was so Memory-Safe
wie möglich ist,
also erst mal, wenn du
das brauchst ja was so memory safe wie möglich ist aber gleichzeitig auch so
viel performance haben soll wie nötig also so wenig wie möglich runtime
checks braucht dann dann ist gut
aber wenn du eine software einfach nur angenehm programmieren können willst
vielleicht auch einfacher erweitern können willst du so ich glaube da ist
alles einfach in Rust rewriten nicht
unbedingt immer das Sinnvollste.
So, haben wir jetzt geguckt, was alles in Rust trendet?
Hm.
Aber Sachen rewriten
in Rust ist ja angesagt, ja.
Okay, haben wir.
Gucken wir nochmal ganz kurz schnell drüber, was Monthly so trendet.
Logitech haben wir schon.
X-Algorithms.
Micro Sandbox.
Das habe ich schon ausprobiert.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
kann man kann man zum beispiel sagen hier msb ron db jahren und schon hat man eine vollwertige
db an vm das jetzt eine richtig echte vm das ist kein container das kann ich euch zeigen
wenn ich hier wird wort installiere und frag mal in welcher welche mann weihmann
läuft und dann sagt der kvm also finde ich micro sandbox ist ganz nice
bisschen wieder vor m champ
eipa und männer translator für die bips da müssen wir gerade mal eine runde
Ah, yes, excellent.
Wo ist der
Sebarro eigentlich, wenn man ihn mal braucht?
Außerdem,
der ist generell in letzter Zeit wenig da.
Sebarro, wo steckst du?
Na gut, der Sebarro ist jetzt leerer,
der hat andere Probleme.
olex pdf pnpm was das
das hat man glaube ich schon mal habe ich auch nicht so genau den sinn davon kapiert
bammel
miese
Okay, nix dabei
So, dann gucken wir jetzt noch eine Sprache
Was wollen wir gucken, Chat?
Komm, wir gucken zwei Sprachen
Wir gucken zwei Sprachen
Eine, die ich mir aussuchen darf
Und eine noch, die ihr euch aussuchen dürft
Ich will mal noch eine Runde Kek-W
Aber C++ ist das Witzige immer
Du siehst Projekte und denkst dir so
Alter, was sind die gedacht?
Holy C, das ist eine gute Idee
Okay, Protobuff FMT hatten wir schon.
Linux-Emulator-Gedöns.
Google-Tester.
Audacity.
Ist am trenden.
So sieht das jetzt aus.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Audacity Cloud Storage.
C++
Replacement for Redis
Okay, Flameshot
Habe ich tatsächlich unter Linux mal
Vor Jahren verwendet
Flameshot
Aber jetzt
Verwende ich einfach Screenshot
Spectacle
Was bei KDE dabei ist
Schon hast du einen
Screenshot
Kannst du gar da drinnen
Kannst sogar drin Sachen
Pixel
Pixelaten hier
Massive Pixelaten
Und drin rummalen
Und dann kannst du es canceln
Audacity 4.0
Kam jetzt raus
Kotlin, Dart und Flutter
Okay, das machen wir
Nach Holy See
Imagegray, Absylons
Legehennen
Playstation 2 Emulator
DuckDB
Chat, ich bin
am überlegen, ob ich auf der Arbeit
nicht DuckDB benutzen soll
für einen Anwendungsfall.
Und zwar, wir sind
dazu verpflichtet, eine Postgres-Datenbank
für 10 Jahre zu archivieren.
Read only.
reicht also letztendlich sind wir nur dazu gezwungen die daten in der post
press datenbank zu archivieren allerdings daily also wir müssen wir
müssen daily die postress datenbank quasi snapshotten und dann für zehn
jahre aufbewahren so dass man wirklich schön tagtäglich nachgucken kann was
sich da geändert hat und ich kann man kann ausdress in einem format
exportieren was lesbar ist für dac db und dann könnte man die queries mit dac
db machen das wäre für so ein lied archiv gar nicht verkehrt
Wurde nicht gerade gekauft.
Keine Ahnung.
Was ist besser als Esculight?
Mit Esculight könntest du aber nicht das machen, was ich vorhabe, glaube ich.
Ach, von AWS, ja.
Noctalia.
Ja, das wollte ich mir auch nochmal angucken.
Aber nachdem ich jetzt ja kein Wayland und Niri verwende,
wahrscheinlich doch nicht.
desk flow mit desk flow mache ich gerade hier mein maus und tastatur sharing zwischen der
windows kiste unter linux kiste jason von modern c++ okay wir gucken uns jetzt mal
an wie hässlich jason handling in modern c++ ist okay examples example verzeichnis gibt schon mal
gar nicht.
Examples.
Okay, das geht ja noch.
Ja, genau.
Das benutzen viele Leute für Niri,
um so zusätzliche Sachen hier in der Leiste
zu machen.
Pass.
Okay, das geht auch noch.
Aber ich möchte es ja vielleicht parsen in irgendeinem Struct.
Wie geht das denn dann?
Das ist auch noch vollkommen fein hier.
Alles okay.
Wie kann man das denn in einem Struct parsen?
Serial 2 from Strings.
O wie L, Alter.
Habe ich eh nicht mal geguckt.
Ein Makro.
Was sonst?
Wir sind im C++ Land.
Ich will das in ein Object?
Gibt es da Custom-Data-Source?
What the fuck?
Das offensichtlichste Beispiel, was jeder verwenden will,
gibt es wieder nicht.
Wie funktioniert das?
Arbiter...
Okay, okay.
Okay, hier, hier.
Struck Person.
Person gleich...
Hä?
Warte mal.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Achso, Struct Initialize.
Das kann doch jetzt nicht euer Ernst sein, oder?
Was?
Aha.
Okay, das geht.
Das geht.
Nicht schlecht.
Das lasse ich mir sogar gefallen,
wie die Bedienung hiervon ist.
Ach nee. Ach so,
das macht das nicht automatisch.
Man muss dafür irgendwas implementieren.
Ja, dann ist es ja wieder
Unsinn. Vielleicht, ohne Scheiß,
vielleicht mit C++
26, wenn es Reflection gibt.
Simplify your life as macros.
Okay.
Tolle Makroname.
Ah ja, gut.
Ich mein...
Jetzt so richtig schön ist es nicht,
aber für C++-Standards ist es schon okay.
Die C++, die sind ja eh...
Da liegt ja die Messlatte niedrig.
So, okay, was trendet in Holy See?
Trendet da überhaupt irgendwas?
Oh, nee.
Holy See trendet nix, Leute.
Was habt ihr gesagt, sollten wir noch aus...
Was sollten wir noch gucken?
Holy See und...
Kotlin.
Das können wir tatsächlich mal machen.
Da habe ich noch nie geguckt, was da trendet.
Kernel ISU.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, was das bedeuten soll.
A kernel-based root solution for Android.
Ach so.
Android-Routen.
Aber du brauchst immer noch ein Android, was exploitable irgendwie ist.
Anquian
Trended
Alles klar
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, Leute
Translate to English
Climbing the Wall
Es ist bestimmt was, um die China-Chinesen-Firewall zu umgehen, hä?
Jaja.
Irgendwas um China-Chinesen-Fireball zu umgehen ist.
Das könnte ich wetten.
Nichts, was wir brauchen.
Noch nicht, Leute.
Noch nicht.
Wir sind aber auf bestem Wege dahin.
Flow.
Modern Feature Rich YouTube and YouTube Music Client.
Okay.
Modern heißt, er sieht auf dem Desktop aus wie auf dem Tablet.
Ja.
Also ich finde YouTube Musik im Browser ist ganz okay.
Was mich an YouTube Musik allerdings nervt ist,
es gibt keine so richtige Discoverability,
oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag.
Also du findest nichts Neues.
Die haben zwar diese Empfehlungen, was dir auch gefallen könnte,
ist aber immer der gleiche Scheiß.
Na, warte mal ab, was mit Chat-Kontrolle und den ganzen Sachen, die noch geplant sind, auf uns zukommt.
Also wir befinden uns auf dem besten Wege dahin.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Vibe-Coding? Kann man machen?
Also für schnell irgendwas ausprobieren?
Also ich mache das auch oft für Ideen zum Beispiel.
So hier, ich will mit Rust ein USB-Gerät lesen.
Mach mal ein minimales Beispiel für.
So, dass man einfach mal ein Gefühl für kriegt, wie sieht das Ganze aus.
Das finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Jetzt ein komplettes Produkt zu Vibe-Coden.
Ohne von der technischen Basis unten drunter noch irgendwie eine Ahnung zu haben.
Das sieht auf den ersten Blick vielleicht verlockend aus, aber das sehe ich ein bisschen skeptisch.
Kommt Chat-Kontrolle.
Chat-Kontrolle kam wieder vor ein paar Monaten.
Das ist alles durchgewunken worden.
Ja, also das sehe ich in der Tat kritisch.
Das ist erstmal verlockend, ja, weil du halt schnell was vorzuweisen hast.
aber ob das lang auf lange frist rein also ob langfristig ein reines vibe coding projekt
es kommt jetzt kommt bestimmt auf das projekt an ja aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
langfristig zu was führt also ich sag nicht dass du nicht teile von einem programm generieren
kannst oder dir von KI
mal drüber lesen lassen kannst oder dir
Vorschläge machen lassen kannst von KI.
Aber
ein reines, ich wipecode
meine komplette Anwendung
von A bis Z,
da weiß ich nicht, ob das auf Dauer
so sinnvoll ist.
Ha!
Rootless Android App,
that boots Alpine Linux.
Ha! Das ist ja witzig.
Ja, das Ding ist,
viele KI-Projekte werden mit Slop,
also viele Open-Source-Projekte werden mit Slop geflutet.
Das Ding, was ich jetzt halt sehe,
ist, dass
viele Models jetzt
ja wenn du sie was fragst auch direkt im internet nach gucken so und ich befürchte wir sind da jetzt
schon ein bisschen in so einem teufelskreis ja models gucken im internet nach und finden
content der von models generiert wurde und dieser content landet an dem internet und die nächsten
Models finden den wieder.
Und ich finde, so ein kleines
Indiz dafür,
dass das durchaus stimmen
könnte, dass wir uns in
einer Endlosschleife befinden
und so einen Teufelskreis
befinden,
ist,
dass
viele KI-Unternehmen aktuell
alte Bücher
kaufen,
einscannen,
ihre Models damit trainieren
und die Bücher dann vernichten.
Weil sie brauchen sie ja nicht mehr.
Ja, um quasi
neue menschliche
neuen menschlichen
Content reinzubekommen.
Aber das finde ich cool hier.
Du kannst einen Alpine starten
auf
Guck mal, Alpine starten
auf Android
und dann ist wahrscheinlich ein X-Server oder sowas dabei
oder keine Ahnung, weil die schreiben, du kannst auch
GUI-Anwendungen
angeblich starten.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz witzig.
Ich habe Android-Geräte
allerdings nur als Dashboard-Panels
an der Wand für meine
Heimautomatisierung.
Wenn ich welche so hätte, die ich benutzen würde,
würde ich das tatsächlich mal installieren und mir angucken.
Weil finde ich die Idee ganz witzig.
Android-Stells, Linux-Command-Library.
Der Simon Schubert!
Was?
Ist das eine Shell oder was?
Ach nee, das ist eine Man-Page-Library.
Das ist eine Man-Page. Braucht man sowas?
In der heutigen Zeit.
Aber man kann ja einfach kurz googeln.
Oder kurz KI fragen.
Edge 2-License.
Okay, One-Liners. Guck mal.
Das viel Wichtigere ist, ist der
4M-Champ da drinnen. Nein, wer hätte das
gedacht?
Max, warst du heute schon
wählen? Ich wohne doch nicht in Sachsen-Anhalt.
Ich hab nur letztens den Wahl-O-Mat gemacht für Sachsen-Anhalt.
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, was rauskommt.
Was kam raus? FDP, ne?
FDP und noch irgendwas Merkwürdiges kam raus.
Irgendwas, von dem ich noch nie was gehört hab.
Glücklicherweise, ne die Grünen waren es nicht,
Glücklicherweise war diese Corona-Impfung-Mikrochip uns alle Partei relativ weit unten.
Die AfD war auch nicht so weit oben, weil ich habe angekreuzt dem Wahl-O-Mat,
Zuwanderung an sich
habe ich nichts dagegen.
Man muss sich halt genau angucken, wen man aufnimmt.
Aber gegen Zuwanderung habe ich
im Prinzip nichts und da war direkt AfD raus.
Bam.
Aber das ist halt das Ding beim Wahl-O-Mat.
Die Sachen sind meistens nicht sonderlich differenziert.
Du kannst halt nur sagen, so eine ganz
allgemeine Sache.
Bam, willst du oder willst du nicht?
Das ist dann halt so vielleicht ein bisschen...
Aber wie willst du es machen?
Kann sich ja nicht jeder das Programm
von allen Parteien durchlesen und dazu kommt auch noch,
selbst wenn du das Programm durchliest,
es gibt ja absolut keine Garantie für,
dass das dann auch gemacht wird.
Was ist denn das?
Run Windows PC Games
and Apps on Android.
Ah, das ist Wine und Box.
Ja, aber Moment, da kannst du nur
uralte Games drauf runnen.
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es da nicht mal Screenshots?
Das ist Mario Galaxy Musik.
Besser. Besser Soundtrack.
Open Source, Android, Desktop,
Civilization.
Open Source Video Editor.
Okay, bei Kotlin findet man tatsächlich ganz interessante Sachen.
Das Ding ist nur, dass mir die ganzen Android-Apps halt nichts bringen.
Head Unit App for Displaying Android Auto.
Ah!
Du kannst mit deinem Tablet zu tun, als ist es ein Auto.
Und dein Handy mit pairen oder so.
Es wäre cool, es wäre richtig cool, wenn es sowas für iOS gäbe.
So, excellent.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, was trendet.
Was habt ihr noch gesagt?
Dart.
Okay, da gucken wir jetzt nochmal ganz schnell, weil das juckt mich eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Aber vielleicht trotzdem mal ganz spannend, was es alles gibt.
Zang Jitsu.
Free Open Source App for Anime.
Aha.
Weeps, wo seid ihr?
Das sieht aber alles überhaupt nicht nach Anime aus hier.
Was soll das sein?
Warum habe ich das
gebuckmarkt?
Vergeht mich das in irgendeiner Art und Weise?
Keine Ahnung.
SteamOS Like Arm Handheld Distro.
Pili Plus.
Die Beschreibung ist Pili Plus.
Okay, jetzt weiß man sofort Bescheid, was Sache ist.
Pili Plus, Leute.
China-Chinesen.
Ah, Bilibili.
Bilibili ist das China-YouTube, gell?
Billy Billy.
Ente.
Ente benutze ich auch,
falls es das ist.
End-to-end Encrypted Cloud for everything.
Ich benutze Enter, Enter-Auth benutze ich.
Enter-Auth benutze ich auch, ja.
Für meine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Blattast selbst
Okay
Excellent
Etwas
Dann gucken wir mal
So
Oder Chat, habt ihr noch irgendwas?
Gibt es irgendwas Wichtiges, worüber wir die Woche reden müssen noch, Chat?
Hab ich irgendwas verpasst?
Muss ich zu irgendwas nochmal einen Senf dazugeben?
Wenn ich vier Tage die Woche nach Frankfurt fahre und da arbeite, kriege ich immer nicht so viel mit.
Was gibt es denn?
Was gibt es denn? Lass mal überlegen.
Was war die Woche? Irgendwas Spannendes.
Ja, diese Berlin-Datenleak-Geschichte war...
Ja gut, das habe ich nur ganz kurz auf Reddit gelesen,
dass der irgendwie seine Firma aufgibt oder so,
weil irgendwas mit seiner Frau war.
So habe ich das auf Reddit gelesen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da Sache ist.
GTA 6 juckt mich nicht.
Ich überlege gerade, war IT-mäßig diese Woche noch irgendwas?
Wie gesagt, dass ganz viele Daten geklaut wurden in Berlin, in der Verwaltung.
Da habe ich ja schon meinen Senf zugegeben.
Ansonsten war irgendwas Spannendes.
Erstmal kurz, Gifa ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass...
Erstmal kurz drüber scrollen.
Der Film ist ganz okay.
Ich habe nichts erwartet beim Gucken.
Und am Ende habe ich mir gedacht, war doch ganz nett.
Warum ihr nicht auf Wi-Fi 8 warten solltet.
Das lassen wir uns gleich auf YouTube von denen erklären.
Aha, Kamerafunktion gesperrt.
Neue Porta-Split.
Ja, das ist ja der Renner in Deutschland.
Seitdem es wieder erwartend, wo keiner damit rechnen konnte, natürlich, so heiß geworden ist diesen Sommer, waren die Dinger ja ausverkauft.
Musik
Also wirklich was Spannendes ist die Woche nicht dabei, oder?
Edler Mini-PC.
Also Mini-PCs interessieren mich nur am Rande.
Was mich interessiert, sind Nasses.
Und ich brauche unbedingt noch ein fünftes Nass, Leute.
Nachdem ja mit den anderen drei schon so viel passiert ist.
Heck, Wade.
Du hast die Probezeit bestanden.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Probezeit von was?
Bist du Fisi?
Oder für welche?
Oder machst du eine Ausbildung?
Oder machst du irgendwie...
Probezeit für was?
Meist gelesen.
Das ist doch auch mal nicht verkehrt.
Ausfall von Exchange. Juckt mich nicht.
Okay, es gab diese Woche echt nicht wirklich viel Spannendes.
Ach, ich weiß
Ich weiß
Du machst eine Ausbildung
Du hast doch letztens geschrieben, du hast über Mr. Robot eine Präsentation gehalten
Oder?
Warst du das?
Ich kann mir das nicht alles merken
Aber ich glaube, das warst du, oder?
Oh, da bringe ich das durcheinander
War das jemand anderes?
Ach stimmt
Ja da erinnere ich mich noch dran
Wer war denn
Der Mr. Robot Presentator
Der ist wahrscheinlich gerade nicht da
Was ist das
So also was haben wir denn heute
Was können wir uns denn heute hier mal angucken auf Youtube
Schluss mit WLAN Frust
Wiener Schnitzel erklärt mit Katze.
Was ist ein Schwachsinn, Alter.
Ey, der Typ ist ja auch...
Der Typ ist übelst abgestürzt, ne?
Der Salt-Typ da.
Das Schnitzel direkt kurz vor dem Panieren. Erst ins Mehl, dann Eier und noch Paniermehl.
Katze drückt das Paniermehl nicht an. Katze legt das Schnitzel in die heiße Pfanne.
Das Schnitzel muss in Butterschmalz schwimmen. Katze schwenkt die Pfanne, sodass das Fett auch auf die Oberseite schwappt.
Katze wendet das Schnitzel nach zwei, drei Minuten und dann ist es fertig. Katze isst beide Schnitzel allein.
Wiener Schnitzel.
Sehr gut. Das ist...
Das musste... Also hätten wir das jetzt nicht gesehen,
wäre...
Schrecklich, ja.
Was sind das wieder für...
Alter!
Was wollen die Shorts von mir?
Chat, haben wir im Stream...
Und ich benutze diesen Browser nur im Stream.
jemals irgendwas von diesem
Content hier geguckt?
Nie.
Warum denkt YouTube, Max, dass
ich will Wohnungsbesichtigung
bei einem Vampir? Das will ich jetzt sehen.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal,
wer das ist.
Was sind das für Shorts,
Alter?
Wer ist das?
Wo lerne ich als Mann am besten Single-Frauen kennen, wenn ich nicht so der Party-Mensch bin?
Das juckt mich nicht.
Mein Make-Off war zu...
WTF, Alter! Was sind das für Shorts?
Könnt ihr mir auch irgendwas Interessantes zeigen?
Dein Trunas braucht Homo-System.
Nicht unbedingt.
Da habe ich meine Zweifel, ob das mein Trunas wirklich braucht.
Using LinkedIn
as a dating app. Es wird ja immer schlimmer.
Da gucke ich mir lieber
Gaben an, wenn irgendwas revealed.
Der AF-Programmer
wieder.
ESP 32P4.
Was kann er wirklich?
Okay.
Was kann der?
Ah, das ist ein Risk.
Ist das?
Das ist was Neues hier von Espressif.
Was, man kann weniger Shorts anklicken?
Wo, hier oben?
Ne.
Wo denn?
Da muss man eigentlich...
Ah, hier.
Und jetzt?
Aber ich bin ja nicht eingeloggt.
Weniger Shorts.
Und wie?
Es geht nur, wenn man eingeloggt ist, oder?
Oh, ist ja doof.
Gibt es vielleicht irgendwas?
Was einfach einem die Shorts komplett heidet?
Ja, die brauche ich.
So, was kann der denn?
Oh, meine Webseite hängt.
Leute, die China-Chinesen haben angefangen zu meinen.
Mein Browser hängt.
Jetzt geht's
Die Seite kackt immer ab
Sobald ich sie anklicke
Okay, ich hab die Seite jetzt zugemacht
Ops, äh, falscher Knopf
Nehmen wir jetzt
ESP32P4
Unter Linux geht das bestimmt
Da meinen die China-Chinesen nicht so viel
Da sagt mir der Tab-Ansatz nichts zu tun
Ich hab genug RAM
Guck mal, wie viel RAM ich frei hab.
Sekunde.
Ich hab...
Guck mal.
Ich hab 40 GB RAM frei. Das sollte reichen.
Heute wäre mein RAM teurer als der ganze PC.
Gut, dass ich das 2022 noch gekauft hab.
Damals war das noch nicht so teuer.
Also, was hat er denn hier?
ESP32, P4. Gibt es da irgendwie ein gescheites Features?
Overview.
Oh je, was hat denn das Ding so?
Product Overview.
Okay, also was hat der denn?
Features
Dual-Core 32-Bit-Risk-Prozessor
67K RAM
64 MB Flash
Ach ne, PS RAM
16 MB Flash
Das ist mehr als genug
Espressif hat mittlerweile so viele Dinger
Da ich da gar nicht richtig durchblicke
Aber ich glaube, dass man mit einem normalen ESP32
Oder einem ESP32
p 32 wie heißt dieses bisschen neuere version davon die am besten fährt weil
die s3 glaube ich sp 32 s3 am besten fährt weil die die beste software
unterstützung haben
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Gehen wir hier rüber.
Story of VS Code Official Documentary.
Eine Stunde 38.
Nee, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Warte mal, ich muss husten.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier?
Leute, wir müssen kurz mal ein bisschen Katzenshorts angucken.
damit ich ordentliche Sachen hier
empfohlen kriege.
Und nicht die ganze Zeit erzählt bekomme,
wo ich Single-Frauen kennenlerne.
Oder wie die Leute sich schminken oder sowas.
Die arme Katz.
Alter, guck mal, was sind das für Dreckssä...
Guck mal, wie der an seiner Katze rumzieht.
Was ein Spast, Alter.
Guck mal, was ein Depp.
Okay, das ist absolut unlustig.
Aber vielleicht reicht es ja schon,
dass ich nicht mehr
diesen ganzen Mist empfohlen bekomme.
Okay, scheint nicht.
Okay, was macht Gaben so den Tag über?
Also er wirkt, egal wo er ist.
Er wirkt, ob er im Schlafzimmer ist, ob er auf dem Boot ist, ob er am Tauchen ist.
er wirkt einfach immer.
Massive work.
Stonks.
Richtiger Macher hier.
Das ist das richtige
Grindset-Mindset, ja.
Lifestyle-Teilzeit.
Wieso? Ist doch kein Problem.
Ich sehe da überhaupt kein Problem drin.
Ist das noch Arbeit oder schon Lifestyle?
Können die Leute, die solche Beiträge sprechen, vielleicht einfach normal reden?
Diese Firma in Friedberg hat eine Vier-Tage-Woche.
Und wer mag, kann sich jederzeit noch mehr Zeit nehmen. Für fast alles.
Jonas hat sich mal irgendwann, ich glaube, er hat sich einen Hund irgendwann angeschafft.
Und da am Anfang war es ein bisschen mit der Betreuung natürlich ein bisschen knifflig. Warum auch nicht?
Oder berufliche Fort- und Weiterentwicklung.
Wir gucken uns jetzt an, was mit dem WLAN hier los ist.
Ja.
Schluss mit WLAN-Frust. Zeig her.
WLAN-Probleme sind so ein bisschen wie Rückenschmerzen.
Fast jeder hat sie irgendwann mal und sobald man sie erwähnt,
klebt einem sofort jemand an der Backe, der meint, die ultimative Lösung dafür parat zu haben.
Also seit ich kein UniFi mehr habe, muss ich euch jetzt ja sagen, also ich weiß, wir haben viele UniFi-Fans im Chat,
aber seitdem ich kein UniFi mehr habe, sondern die gebrauchten Ruckus-Access-Points von Ebay gekauft habe,
habe ich keine WLAN-Probleme mehr.
Auf der Familienfeier ist dann der selbsternannte Technikexperte, der zwischen Kartoffelsalat und Nachtisch erklärt,
dass man unter WiFi 7 ja sowieso nichts mehr kaufen dürfe
und dass WiFi 8 dann endlich alles besser machen werde.
Man muss auf jeden Fall auf die...
Also meine Access Points hier sind...
Was sind denn die überhaupt?
AX?
Was ist denn AX?
WiFi 6? Nee.
Was kam davor? AC?
5?
Okay, gucken wir mal. Das ist AC, ein AC Access Point. Habe ich hier seit Jahren jetzt schon.
Und ich habe damit überhaupt keine Schmerzen. Seitdem ich die habe, funktioniert es einfach.
Neue Geräte warten, wenn man dieses oder jenes Problem hat.
Das klingt dann erstmal kompetent, ist aber meist eher halbwissen, das am Ende teuer für euch werden kann.
Ja, das Ding ist vor allem, die Frage ist halt, also muss man ja mehrere Sachen sagen.
Du brauchst erstmal Clients, die das unterstützen, dass dir das was bringt.
So.
Dann ist halt die Frage, willst du deine Infrastruktur komplett da alle paar Jahre austauschen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und brauchst du das von der Performance?
Und das nächste ist, was oftmals, ich sage nicht immer, aber oftmals der Fall ist, höhere Bandbreite sorgt in der Regel dafür, dass die Reichweite geringer ist. Das ist einfach so.
... kann, wenn ihr danach überzeugt seid, dass ihr unbedingt das Neueste vom Neuesten kaufen müsst.
Und am Ende feststellt, dass das eure Probleme gar nicht löst.
Ob euer WLAN gut funktioniert, hängt nämlich von wesentlich mehr Faktoren ab,
als dem Standard, mit dem die Geräte funken.
Das stimmt.
Wenn ihr euer Portemonnaie nicht sinnlos in ein schweineteures Mesh-Set oder einen überzogenen Router kippt...
Wisst ihr, mit welchem Access Point ich die wenigsten Probleme bzw. die beste Abdeckung im Haus hatte?
Also wir reden jetzt von einem Access Point.
Das war ein uralter Linksys.
Also richtig, richtig alt.
Also so richtig.
Ne, nicht Linksys.
Wie heißt
TP-Link?
Ich weiß es gar nicht. So ein richtig,
richtig alter
Moment, ich
such da jetzt mal bei Amazon.
Ich such da jetzt mal bei Amazon, weil
das Ding ist wirklich richtig alt.
Nach was such ich
denn da jetzt bei Amazon? WLAN, hä?
Amazon nervt nicht rum. WLAN. Wir suchen mal
WLAN. Oder WiFi.
Ne?
Alter, kann das sein, dass er die ganz alten Sachen gar nicht mehr durchsucht?
Das müsste 2006 gewesen sein oder so.
Ey, Amazon hat keine so alte History mehr.
Was ist da los?
Könnte das der...
Ich hab hier...
Irgendwann hab ich mal so einen gekauft.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht
darüber bewusst, dass ich den
gekauft habe.
Aber Amazon sagt,
den habe ich gekauft. Ich habe dieses Gerät nie gesehen,
Leute.
Nie gesehen. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht,
was das für ein Nexus Point ist, aber laut Amazon
habe ich den gekauft.
Was ist das für... Ohne Scheiß.
Ich habe dieses Gerät nie gesehen.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
dass ich sowas habe.
Okay. Zumindest, ich glaube, es war Linksys versus TP. Es war nicht Netgear. Es war, glaube ich, Linksys Access Point 2,4. Es war so ein richtig altes Drecksding.
Wenn ich das Ding...
Das sah aber nicht so aus.
Das war ne...
Dann war es doch...
Da war es doch ein TP-Link.
Das war so ein ganz billiger, kleiner, weißer Kasten.
Komplett viereckig.
Alt.
Okay, findet man nicht.
Zumindest mit dem Access Point.
Die Dinger waren wirklich...
Mit dem hatte ich die beste Abdeckung
von nur einem Access Point im Haus,
weil da war ein lahmes Fuck
und hat eine große Reichweite gehabt.
Aber keine Ahnung, was das für einer war.
Meinst du den, den jeder hatte?
Ja, du meinst die hier, ne?
Die hatte gefühlt jeder mal.
Die Dinger.
Den hatte ich aber nicht.
Moment, was ist das hier?
Das war auch so ganz...
Okay.
TL-WR84-1N.
Nee.
Noch älter.
Egal.
Ist auch egal, was ich da für ein Access Point...
Zumindest mit dem habe ich die beste Abdeckung im Haus.
Wie gesagt, mit nur einem Access Point.
Ich brauche gerade fürs Haus neue Videoklingel, Kameras, APs und Switche.
Ich wollte alle in Unify gehen.
Kann man schon machen, Unify ist in Ordnung.
Ja.
wie gesagt ich bin nicht der größte unified fan aber dinge funktionieren
prinzipiell schon
bei der klingel
würde ich mir ein bisschen was weiß ich nicht
video klingeln sind die erst die zeichen ja nicht permanent auf ob das ist okay
es hat das ding wenn du eine ip klingel hast dann und du netzwerk probleme hast
dann geht
die Klingel nicht mehr
weiß nicht ob man sich da so dran binden will
also ich hab noch so eine ganz olle Klingel
mit Draht in der Wand
und zwei Gegensprechtelefonen
aber die kann man halbwegs smart machen
Es gibt ein Telefonmodul dafür.
Das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Das ist nicht so geil.
Das brauche ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich bin eh nie von unterwegs dran gegangen.
Und das Telefon lasse ich klingeln.
Da habe ich mir selbst was gebaut.
Gucke einfach, welche Spannung anliegt da drauf.
Mit so einem kleinen Analog-Digital-Konverter.
Und dann lasse ich das Telefon klingeln.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, wenn das Video fertig ist.
...klären wir in diesem Video einmal verständlich, was die neuen WLAN-Standards von den alten unterscheidet und wo die echten Geschwindigkeitsturbos warten.
Warte mal, jetzt weiß ich, jetzt weiß ich, nach was ich suchen kann.
Jetzt weiß ich, nach was ich suchen kann.
Hier.
DP-Link 11N hieß der Kram damals.
Das ist der aber nicht.
Okay, okay, okay.
WLAN-Standards.
wir müssen jetzt gucken
okay was gab es
davor
ne 5 GHz konnte
meins definitiv noch nicht
ok WLAN Standards
Wikipedia
IEEE 802.11
yeah
also
A, B, G.
G.
Dann war das G.
Das war nämlich noch nicht,
und es war auf jeden Fall nicht 2,5.
Das ist Zeug, ey.
Hast doch einen Link, Sys.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt auch wurscht. Wir gucken jetzt weiter.
Könnt ihr am Ende selbst eine informierte Entscheidung treffen,
die dann euer Heimnetz wirklich beschleunigt.
Aber Spoiler, ihr müsst wahrscheinlich nicht auf Wi-Fi 8 warten.
Los geht's.
Moment mal, du wohnst in Europa,
aber lagerst deine E-Mails und andere Daten in den USA
bei Microsoft, Google, Yahoo.
Dann ist es jetzt an der Zeit,
zu einem europäischen Cloud-Anbieter zu wechseln.
Infomaniac ist ein Schweizer,
ihr am MyK-Suite Plus findet ihr in der Beschreibung.
Nun, um zu verstehen, was die WLAN-Standards so ausmacht
und wann WLAN gut funktioniert,
müsst ihr grob nachvollziehen können, wie WLAN überhaupt arbeitet.
Wir schauen uns also einmal ganz kurz die wichtigsten Grundlagen an,
die euer WLAN-Router wahrscheinlich beherrscht, wenn ihr ihn innerhalb der letzten 10 Jahre gekauft habt.
Danach geht es an das, was die neuen Standards besser machen.
Aber keine Panik, wir brechen es etwas runter und haben eine Menge Vergleiche aus dem Alltag im Gepäck.
Ihr müsst also nicht nochmal ein Semester Hochfrequenztechnik belegen, um hier mitzukommen.
Nahezu alle halbwegs modernen WLAN-Router beherrschen heute zwei Frequenzbänder.
2,4 und 5 GHz.
Diese Bereiche sind in Deutschland...
Wobei mittlerweile gibt es ja auch 6 GHz, oder?
Deutschland hat allgemein Zuteilungen uns allen zur Nutzung freigegeben.
Heißt, jeder darf sie ohne separate Lizenz benutzen, solange er sich an die Einschränkungen hält, die die Zuteilung vorgibt.
Darunter fällt zum Beispiel die Sendeleistung, die beschränkt ist, damit Nachbarn auch was von den Frequenzen haben.
Und so oder so ähnlich wie in Deutschland sind diese Frequenzbänder nahezu weltweit freigegeben.
Das 2,4 GHz Band war 1993 das erste Band, das für WLAN bzw. die Vorgängerstandards freigegeben wurde.
Es bietet einen guten Kompromiss zwischen Kanalbreite und Reichweite, denn je höher die Frequenz, desto stärker wird sie von den Objekten in der Umgebung und durch die Luft gedämpft.
Das ist das, was ich auch vorhin gesagt habe.
2002 hat man dann noch das 5 GHz Band freigegeben, was dann ab den frühen 2010ern immer mehr genutzt wurde, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt der Bandbreitenbedarf und die Anzahl der Geräte gestiegen sind.
Der Grund ist ganz einfach. Will man mehr Datendurchsatz, muss man unter anderem die Kanäle breiter machen und dafür brauchen wir nun mal Platz.
Und dafür brauchen wir nun mal Platz.
Das ist doch nicht, das kann man doch verstehen, oder nicht?
Marco Schäler ist verstanden.
Während die 2,4 GHz-Freigabe nur 83 MHz breit ist,
hat man bei 5 GHz satte 455 MHz zur Verfügung.
Dafür ist wichtig zu wissen, dass ein Kanal für hohe Datenraten
mindestens 40 oder besser 80 MHz breit sein sollte.
Die neueren Standards können sogar 160 oder 320 MHz.
Um mehr Platz für sowas zu schaffen, kam 2021 noch das 6 GHz-Band dazu.
Aber darüber sprechen wir gleich, wenn es um WiFi geht.
Ja, das habe ich auch so im Kopf, dass es noch eh geht.
Vorher schauen wir uns an, wie WLAN eigentlich sendet und das ist wichtig, um später zu begreifen, warum es da in den neuen Standards echte Verbesserungen gibt.
WLAN ist eine Halbduplex-Funktechnik. Das heißt, euer Router und eure Geräte reden auf demselben Kanal, auf derselben Frequenz miteinander und es gibt keine Trennung zwischen Sende- und Empfangsrichtung.
Außerdem belegen die Geräte auch immer gleich den gesamten Kanal, sodass keine Lücken bleiben.
Wie bei einem echten Gespräch zwischen Menschen, zum Beispiel in einer Kneipe an einem Tisch, bedeutet das, dass immer nur einer senden kann, wenn es in einem bestimmten Umkreis verständlich bleiben soll.
WLAN-Geräte machen das ähnlich wie wir Menschen, vereinfacht gesprochen. Sie lauschen zunächst auf dem Kanal nach Signalen und wenn sich eine Lücke ergibt, fangen sie an zu senden. Sehen sie aber ein anderes Signal, warten sie eine zufällige Zeit und der Prozess beginnt von vorne. Wir reden hier allerdings über...
Das ist ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen wie früher.
Das hattet ihr bestimmt in der Berufsschule auch.
Da gab es doch auch bei den allerersten Internetstandards, da gab es doch auch diese Geschichte mit,
du musst lauschen, ob frei ist, dann kannst du was senden.
Wenn zwei senden, gibt es irgendwie eine Kollision.
Dann gibt es irgendwie so ein Kollisionssignal und dann warten alle wieder zufällig.
Und sowas, wie hieß das denn?
Da gab es so ein komisches Wort für CD, irgendwas, CSMA-CD.
Ja, das ist das da, oder?
Ich erinnere mich noch.
Ja, genau.
Mikro- bis Millisekundenzeiträume, die für uns als Menschen nicht wahrnehmbar sind, wenn das WLAN normal funktioniert.
Nur so klappen Anwendungen wie IP-Telefonie, obwohl WLAN sehr schneller Wechsel ist und kein gleichzeitiges Senden und Empfangen von Router und Endgerät.
Dieses einfache Lauschen vor dem Senden bedeutet aber auch, dass Geräte mit älteren WLAN-Standards in sehr dichten Nachbarschaften schnell langsam werden, weil sie eben viele Signale sehen und mit ihren eigenen, sehr langsamen Aussendungen lange warten müssen.
Dabei ist es egal, ob das Signal vom eigenen Router kommt und wichtig ist oder von irgendeinem schwach empfangenen Smartphone in einem fremden Nachbar-WLAN.
Stellt euch das so vor, wenn ihr in einer Kneipe sitzt und nicht reden dürft, weil drei Tische weiter schon jemand spricht.
Halt, stopp! Jetzt reicht es!
Hallo, hallo, bleib stehen!
Oh, wie sie lustig sein wollen.
Nein, jetzt red ich!
Weil so weder ein Kneipenabend noch WLAN Spaß macht, gibt es seit Wi-Fi 6 ein paar Erweiterungen,
die WLAN mehr wie einen tollen Kneipenabend werden lassen,
wo kleine Grüppchen an vielen Tischen reden können und sich jeweils gegenseitig rausfiltern.
Aber dazu kommen wir später.
Die Datenübertragung funktioniert bei WLAN, indem der Sender kleine Signale aneinander reiht, die dann jeweils in Mikrosekundenintervallen zwischen 2 und 12 Bit übertragen.
Jetzt wissen wir aber voll Bescheid.
Das klingt erstmal wenig, aber nimmt man viele dieser Träger, die das entsprechend schnell tun und das macht WLAN halt, erreicht man die hohen Datenraten bis in den Gigabit-Bereich.
Wir skippen mal den Part, wie WLAN funktioniert.
Aber weil der weitere WLAN-Trick heißt MIMO.
Ja, okay. MIMO, bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob ich das im Kopf richtig zusammenbekomme.
Mimo ist es doch, mehrere Sachen parallel zu senden und zu empfangen, oder? Also wenn der Router irgendwie mehrere Antennen hat und mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig quasi senden, empfangen kann auf mehreren Frequenzen, irgendwie so.
Die ersten WLAN-Standards nutzten jeweils nur eine Antenne, um Daten zu übertragen.
Ja, genau. Die Geschichte ist das.
Die waren nur zum Rausrechnen von Störungen gedacht.
Mit WiFi 4 oder wie es früher hieß, IEEE 802.11n, kam dann aber MIMO als feste Funktion hinzu.
MIMO steht für Multiple Input, Multiple Output und bedeutet grob,
dass mehrere Antennen gleichzeitig auf derselben Frequenz unterschiedliche Datenströme senden und empfangen.
Das widerspricht auf den ersten Blick dem, was wir eben zur Frequenznutzung erzählt haben, nämlich, dass eigentlich immer nur einer senden darf.
Aber MIMO macht sich zunutze, dass sich elektromagnetische Wellen von zwei oder mehr Antennen unterschiedlich im Raum ausbreiten, auch wenn die Antennen nur leicht versetzt sind.
Ist dem Empfänger bekannt, dass das passiert, kann er die Signale wieder auseinanderrechnen.
Stellt euch zwei Personen vor, die gleichzeitig unterschiedliche...
Das haben sich aber auch ein paar High-IQ-Leute ausgedacht, oder?
Sätze in leicht unterschiedliche Richtungen im Raum sprechen, während dann auf der anderen Seite zwei Mikrofone stehen.
Beide Mikrofone hören zwar beide Stimmen, aber nicht exakt gleich.
An einem kommt die erste Stimme etwas lauter an, während am anderen die zweite gut zu hören ist.
Dazu kommen Reflexionen von Wänden und Gegenständen, durch die sich die Laufzeit und Stärke der Signale unterscheiden.
Aus diesen Unterschieden kann der Empfänger die beiden Stimmen, die beiden Datenströme, wieder auseinanderrechnen.
Im Idealfall führt das zur Vervielfachung der Datenrate um die Anzahl der Antennen.
Bei WiFi 4 waren das maximal vier, bei WiFi 5 sind es acht.
In der Praxis hat natürlich kaum ein Mobilgerät acht WLAN-Antennen.
Meistens sind es nur zwei, weil wir ja nicht sinnvoll ins Gehäuse passen.
Aber ab WiFi 5 hat man trotzdem was von einem Router mit vielen Antennen.
Denn in diesem Standard kam Multi-User-Memo dazu.
Das heißt, dass der Router im Downstream mehrere Clients über unterschiedliche Antennen gleichzeitig ansprechen kann.
Das ging mit vorherigen Standards nicht, sodass Latenz und Datenrate auf den einzelnen Geräten profitieren.
Ein Router mit vier Antennen kann zum Beispiel zwei Clients mit je zwei Antennen ansprechen.
In Rückrichtung, also zum Router, ging das mit WiFi 5 aber noch nicht.
So, damit haben wir praktisch erstmal zusammen, was WLAN bis WiFi 5 ausgemacht hat.
Kanäle auf 2,4 und 5 GHz, relativ einfache Kanalzugriffstechnik, senden immer auf gesamter Kanalbreite und MIMO vom Router zum Endgerät.
Jetzt kommen wir zu WiFi 6.
Ja, ich glaube bei WiFi 6 wird es wirklich abgedreht langsam.
Und das hat wirklich einige ordentliche Verbesserungen gegenüber den vorherigen Standards im Gepäck.
Zwei der wichtigsten, die man zweifelsohne auch als Geschwindigkeitsturbo bezeichnen kann, sind BSS-Coloring und Spatial Reuse.
Absolut keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Diese beiden Protokollerweiterungen machen WLAN zu dem tollen Kneipenabend, den wir vorhin schon erwähnt haben,
wo viele kleine Grüppchen kommunizieren können, obwohl sie sich gegenseitig hören.
BSS-Coloring gibt jedem WLAN-Signal ein...
Die haben aber auch schon geile Benamungen wieder für alles, oder?
Eine Farbe.
BSS-Coloring.
Tatsächlich ist es eine Zahl zwischen 1 und 63, die der Router auswürfelt und den Clients mitteilt.
Alle Geräte im Netz senden ab dann mit dieser Farbe und können daran erkennen, dass es sich um ein Signal aus dem eigenen Netz handelt.
Ist es jedoch kein Signal aus dem eigenen Netz, tritt Spatial Reuse in Aktion und hebt die Schwelle an, ab der der Kanal als frei interpretiert wird.
Das heißt, alle Geräte kommen schneller zum Senden, auch wenn viele WLANs aus der Nachbarschaft da sind.
Und kürzere Wartezeiten erhöhen am Ende ja die Datenrate.
Von dieser Funktion profitiert ihr also ganz besonders, wenn ihr in Mehrfamilienhäusern wohnt.
Dort sind die Kanäle ja typischerweise ziemlich voll und somit die Wartezeiten lang.
Höhere Datenrate gibt es bei WiFi 6 aber auch, weil es bis zu 10 Bit pro Sendedurchgang und Träger übertragen kann.
Da habe ich mir noch nie Gedanken zugemacht.
Bei WiFi 5. Guter Empfang natürlich vorausgesetzt.
Durch die 2 Bit mehr ergibt sich eine Steigerung von immerhin 30 bis 40 Prozent.
während bei WiFi 5 mit 80 MHz Kanalbreite und zwei MIMO-Streams rund 867 Mbit pro Sekunde möglich sind.
In der Theorie?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, in der Theorie. Praktisch ist es deutlich weniger.
1200 Mbit pro Sekunde.
Natürlich ist das, was am Ende wirklich nutzbar ist, stark von der Umgebung abhängig,
aber mit BSS-Coloring, Spatial Reuse und mehr Bit pro Sendedurchgang ist man schon mal deutlich schneller unterwegs.
Verbesserungen gibt es aber auch bei der Latenz und dem Datendurchsatz bei Netzen mit vielen Geräten.
Wi-Fi 6 kann jetzt nämlich nicht nur MIMO vom Gerät zum Router, also das Mehrantennenverfahren, was wir eben besprochen haben.
Bei Wi-Fi 6 kann der Router den Kanal auch auf mehrere Geräte aufteilen.
Das ging vorher nicht, wenn mit Wi-Fi 5...
Oh, da waren wirklich wieder irgendwelche Massive Big Brain Leute dabei, die sich das ausgedacht haben.
Oder das Endgerät gesendet hat, war immer der gesamte Kanal belegt und ein Gerät konnte jeweils nur ein anderes ansprechen.
Also zum Beispiel...
IRQ.
...euer Smartphone oder euer Smartphone...
Der kann aber viele MIMO-Streams machen.
Jetzt mit WiFi 6 kann der Router den Kanal in sogenannte Resource Units unterteilen und in einem Sendedurchgang gleich mehrere Geräte ansprechen.
Dafür guckt sich der Router bei jedem Durchgang erneut an, wie viele Pakete er gerade für welches Gerät in seiner Warteschlange hat und unterteilt dann den Kanal.
Eure Schaltsteckdose, die vielleicht nur eine kurze Antwort auf ein Status-Paket bekommen soll, also wenige hundert Byte, kriegt dann wahrscheinlich weniger vom Kanal ab,
als zum Beispiel euer Medienstick, der gerade ein 4K-Video mit 35 Megabit pro Sekunde streamt.
Mit WiFi 5 hätte der Router einen gesamten Sendevorgang für die Steckdose vergeuden müssen, was dann bei vielen Schaltsteckdosen und anderen sehr langsamen WLAN-Geräten durchaus einen signifikanten...
Die Pro-Fraggers, die spielen eh nicht über WLAN, sondern über Kabel. Kabelbeste.
...Effekt auf die Datenrate haben kann. Schließlich brauchen die auch Sendezeit. Das Ganze geht auch von den Geräten zum Router.
Dabei melden die Geräte in WLAN-Paketen, die sie sowieso senden, ihren Bedarf an.
Der Router sagt, in welchem Teil des Kanals die Geräte senden dürfen und dann senden alle mehr oder minder gleichzeitig.
Voraussetzung für diese Geschmeidigkeit ist natürlich, dass alle Geräte WiFi 6 können.
Viele der WiFi 6 Features erfordern schlicht mehr Rechenleistung und Funktionen in Hardware, die sich aber nicht durch ein Update nachrüsten lassen.
Aber eigentlich alle WiFi 6 Router sind rückwärtskompatibel, sodass die älteren Geräte in den älteren Standorten sind.
Die spielen Fortnite auf dem iPhone. Wie ist das eigentlich mit Fortnite auf dem iPhone?
gibt es das denn noch?
Weil ich habe die letzten Jahre
über immer mitbekommen, Epic hat Probleme
mit Apple und dem App Store.
Und zwischenzeitlich
gab es das mal nicht, dann gab es das wieder
und keiner hat es versorgen können.
Durch den weiter gestiegenen Bandbreitenbedarf
hat die EU bzw. bei uns die hiesige
Bundesnetzagentur 2021
den 6 GHz Frequenzbereich freigegeben.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Der Bereich geht von
5945 MHz bis
6425 MHz bietet also riesige 480 MHz Bandbreite.
Hier habt ihr also noch mehr Platz für sehr breite Kanäle wie 160 oder 320 MHz,
die die Voraussetzung für WLAN im Gigabit-Bereich sind.
Und in Stadien zum Beispiel hilft es wiederum, Geräte auf viele Access-Points bzw. Kanäle zu verteilen.
Allerdings heißt WiFi 6 Unterstützung bei einem Router oder Laptop nicht automatisch,
dass auch 6 GHz funktioniert, denn einen Zwang gibt es da nicht
und bislang bauen die Hersteller das eher in höherpreisige Geräte ein.
Und natürlich muss das Endgerät das auch können.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel ein Mesh-Set kauft und das explizit, um kein Kabel ziehen zu müssen.
Teurere Mesh-Sets haben nämlich oft ein separates Interface für den Backbone,
sodass das Set zwar auf 2,4 GHz und 5 GHz mit euren Geräten spricht, aber auf 6 GHz mit der Mesh-Zentrale.
Durch die etwas geringere Reichweite und Nutzerzahlen auf 6 GHz kann es dort halt schneller laufen als bei 5 GHz.
Aber kommen wir mal zu WiFi 7.
WiFi 7 bringt alles mit, was WiFi 6 so kann und natürlich noch einiges mehr.
Das Spannendste ist in unseren Augen MLO, Multi-Link Operation.
Mit MLO können Geräte auf mehreren Frequenzbändern gleichzeitig die Verbindung zum Router halten und auch Daten übertragen,
sodass sich die nutzbare Datenrate weiter erhöht.
Bündelt MLO beispielsweise einen 5 GHz Kanal und einen 6 GHz Kanal,
können sich daraus auch bei schlechterem Empfang Gigabit-Datenraten ergeben.
Eine Kombination aus 2,4 und 5 oder 6 GHz erhöht die Stabilität an der Reichweitengrenze,
weil 2,4 GHz typischerweise etwas weiter reicht als die beiden oberen Frequenzbänder.
Dieses Feature ist also ein echter Gewinn für alle, die viel Datenrate und gleichzeitig
Stabilität wollen.
Es gibt aber noch weitere Verbesserungen, was das effiziente Senden angeht.
WiFi 7 kann gestörte Kanalanteile einfach ausklammern und so verhindern, dass ein Teil
der Datenübertragung gestört wird und erneut gesendet werden muss.
Außerdem unterstützt es jetzt 320 MHz breite Kanäle und 12 Bit pro Sendedurchgang, sodass
es nochmal grob 20% schneller als bei WiFi 6 zu gehen kann.
Die Frage, die ich mir da stelle, ist immer, also, was musst du auf deinem iPhone machen oder auf deinem mobilen Endgerät machen, wo du Gigabit brauchst?
Also, ich kann mir da eigentlich nur vorstellen, jemand, der im WLAN hängt mit seinem MacBook oder so und auf irgendeinen Nas-Share zugreifen will für Video-Editieren oder so.
Weil für normale Smartphone-Usage, sag ich mal, wenn da 50 Mbit ankommen, reicht das dicke.
Also sprich, auch irgendwo im Garten oder so.
Daniel Lull, Dankeschön. 36 Jahre.
Bock. Massive Sub hier.
wieder unter der Voraussetzung, dass der Empfang gut ist.
Theoretisch kann WiFi 7 auch bis zu 16 MIMO-Streams statt 8,
wie bei WiFi 6 und 5.
Aber wie vorhin schon gesagt, so viele Antennen unterzubringen,
ist schwierig und so einen Mesh-Router kann man auch nicht unendlich groß machen.
Jetzt zu WiFi 8.
WiFi 8 alias I-Trippi 802.11n alias Ultra High Reliance ...
BN! Das habe ich auch noch nicht gehört.
Wir sind jetzt beim BN.
... findet sich aktuell noch im Entwurfsstatus.
Das heißt, dass derzeit eine Gruppe bei der I-Triple-I an dem neuen Standard arbeitet und sich...
Also ist quasi wie C++26 nur für Wi-Fi.
Einige wichtige Funktionen stehen aber schon fest.
Wobei, nee, ist es nicht, weil bei so neuen C++-Standards kommt ja zum größten Teil nur irgendwelche unleserliche Blödsinn dabei.
Die Wi-Fi-Standards machen das Ganze ja wohl auch wirklich besser.
Koordination von Sendezeit und Frequenznutzung zwischen mehreren Access-Points eines Netzes,
besseres Roaming, also schnellerer Übergang zwischen Access Points, wenn man sich mit einem Gerät bewegt
und robustere Verbindung an der Reichweitengrenze.
Was es aber wahrscheinlich nicht mitbringen wird, ist einen weiteren Bandbreitenschub.
Das reicht ja auch.
Denn die WiFi 7-Karameter decken den aktuellen Bedarf schon sehr gut ab.
Das reicht ja auch, Dicke.
Auch die Modulationsstufen bringen ihre eigenen Herausforderungen bei der Hardwareentwicklung mit.
In unseren Augen sind ein Großteil der WiFi 8-Funktionen hauptsächlich für Firmen mit sehr vielen Geräten
oder Betreiber von Veranstaltungsstätten wirklich spannend.
Natürlich profitieren am Ende alle Nutzer davon, wenn es ein Stück flotter läuft.
Von brauchen kann im Heimbereich eigentlich keine Rede sein.
Es lohnt sich also für euch schlicht nicht, daheim auf WiFi 8 zu warten, wenn ihr Probleme mit eurem WLAN habt.
Bis die ersten Router mit Vorab-Varianten...
Vor allem, wie gesagt, du brauchst doch immer Geräte, die das können.
...vor WiFi 8 auftauchen werden, wird wahrscheinlich noch ein Jahr vergehen.
Und bis sich die Spezifikation bei Mobilgeräten durchgesetzt hat, wird es vermutlich 2030 sein.
Damit bleibt für die Auswahl der Hardware die Frage, WiFi 6 oder 7 und mit oder ohne 6 GHz.
oder reicht vielleicht schon ein gebrauchter Wi-Fi 5 Router?
Die Antwort darauf ist natürlich, wie immer, es hängt davon ab.
In unserem Video zum Thema Glasfaserrouter hatten wir ja ab 14 Minuten 19 die Fritzbox 7520 als Gebrauchgerät empfohlen,
weil man sich mit ihr für rund 60 Euro ein Set für Glasfaser zusammenstellen kann.
Die 7520 ist ein Wi-Fi 5 Gerät und damit für euch spannend, wenn eure Anforderungen gering sind und ihr wenig Nachbarnetze habt.
Wenn ihr also mit 100 bis 300 Megabit pro Sekunde Nutzdatenrate zufrieden seid und zum Beispiel in einem Einfamilienhausviertel
oder auf dem Dorf wohnt, kann das Gerät für euch völlig genügen.
Auch für die erste eigene Wohnung mit drei, vier, fünf Geräten
wird es wahrscheinlich völlig reichen,
selbst wenn da ein paar Nachbarwälder ans Meer sichtbar sind.
Kauft ihr jedoch neu und mit höheren Anforderungen an Geschwindigkeit,
Latenz und Zuverlässigkeit, solltet ihr auf Wi-Fi 6 nicht verzichten.
Die eben besprochenen Verbesserungen für den Kanalzugriff
helfen doch sehr, mehr aus dem Funkspektrum rauszuholen.
Und wenn ihr zum Beispiel...
Also ganz ehrlich, juckt mich alles nicht.
ich bleibe bei meinen Wi-Fi 5 Access Points
bis ich
irgendwann einen Anwendungsfall
habe, warum ich
unbedingt was anderes brauche
und wahrscheinlich
wird es eher
so sein, dass die irgendwann
mal so ein richtig krasses Security Problem
bekommen, weil irgendwelche
alten Verschlüsselungsstandards
geknackt wurden oder sonst was, dann werde
ich die austauschen, aber das ist aktuell
nicht absehbar. Ich mach mal kurz
wartet mal, ich mach mal kurz einen Speedtest
bei mir hier
auf dem Handy
Speed
Speedtest
ich bin jetzt nicht in der allerbesten
Position hier
achso, ich teste das gerade im Web
ich sollte es vielleicht besser über die App machen
ah wartet mal, ich mach das mal besser
über die App, Speedtest App
so
Ja, 100 Mbit ungefähr.
Ungefähr 100 Mbit
habe ich gerade.
Das ist doch in Ordnung.
Also,
das ist jetzt nicht krass schnell
oder so,
Aber vollkommen ausreichend. Und dafür habe ich easy WLAN Abdeckung vom Dach bis in den Keller, von vorne bis hinten im Haus, Terrasse bis zum Eingang vom Garten. Brauche ich irgendwas mehr?
ich habe bisher auf meinen mobilen Endgeräten
noch nichts gemacht, wo ich gesagt hätte, oh,
das geht jetzt nicht, weil
nur 90 Mbit.
Oder auch, oh, weil nur
40 Mbit.
Naja.
Wenn ihr einen größeren Kabel- oder Glasfasertarif ausschöpfen
wollt, kommt ihr mit WiFi 6 definitiv weiter.
Gerade Mesh-Sets profitieren sehr
davon, untereinander mit schnellen Datenraten
sprechen zu können, selbst wenn eure Geräte
Und ich habe zwei Access Points aktuell.
Ich habe einen Access Point im ersten Stock hängen und ich habe einen Access Point im Keller hängen.
Der im Keller hängt ein bisschen weiter vorne, dass das Terrasse und so noch gut mit abgedeckt ist.
Fertig.
Beide hängen per Netzwerkkabel hier oben am Router dran.
Und das funzt.
Was tatsächlich ein bisschen was gebracht hat, ist den Access Point richtig hinzuhängen, an die Decke zu hängen.
Das hat tatsächlich was gebracht.
Weil die für das professionelle Umfeld gedachten Access Points, die sind dafür gedacht, meistens quasi so horizontal an der Decke montiert zu werden.
Das von diesem Abstrahlverhalten.
Wohingegen Sachen wie die Fritzbox, die sind eher dafür gedacht, die auf den Tisch zu stellen.
Das hat ein bisschen was gebracht, quasi kopfüber an die Decke zu hängen.
Nicht unbedingt unterstützen.
Aber es war vorher auch okay.
Die Abstandsfähigkeit sich für euch lohnt.
Die kostet ja zwangsläufig etwas mehr.
hängt stark von eurer Funkumgebung und euren Anforderungen ab.
Wenn ihr viele Nachbar-WLANs seht und gleichzeitig aber einen Glasfaseranschluss
mit mehreren 100 Megabit pro Sekunde oder 1 Gigabit pro Sekunde ausschöpfen wollt,
aber keine Kabel ziehen könnt oder wollt, erhöht ein...
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Wenn du einen Desktop-PC hast, du willst mit dem Desktop-PC per WLAN quasi ins Internet
und dort volle Bandbreite, beziehungsweise willst du vielleicht sogar auf dein NAS zugreifen irgendwie,
über WLAN mit voller Bandbreite, vielleicht hast du ja wirklich auch einen 2,5, 5, 10 Gignas und willst da wirklich das Maximum, was geht, übers WLAN rausholen, okay, dann lasse ich mir das gefallen, aber wie gesagt, Kabelbeste, der Desktop ist dran per Kabel, drüben im Wohnzimmer, der Kram ist dran per Kabel, die Access Points selber sind dran per Kabel,
das ist eigentlich alles per Kabel angeschlossen, außer halt
mobile Endgeräte und Tablets.
Ein Mesh-Set mit 6 GHz
Funkmodi. Und die ganzen
ESP32 Sachen, die ich hier rumhängen
hab und
Klübieren, also Leuchtmittelsachen,
die coolen Leute, die heutzutage dazu,
so WLAN-Klübieren und so. Das ist alles
WLAN, aber das ist halt alles nix, was
Bandbreite braucht.
Da war mir die Feature-Unterstützung
des Access-Points wichtiger.
Also mir war zum Beispiel wichtig, dass der Access Point unterstützt, pro Gerät ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort haben zu können. Das war mir viel wichtiger damals bei den Access Points.
Da kriegt nämlich jedes IoT-Gerät bei mir ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort.
Wohlgemerkt, alle für das gleiche WLAN, aber alle mit anderen Passwörtern.
Und wenn ich dann ein WLAN-Gerät wegschmeiße, lösche ich das einfach und gut ist.
Gleichzeitig mit mehreren 100 Megabit pro Sekunde versorgen wollen oder mittels MLO die Chancen verbessern möchten, dass das Mesh-Set ultra schnell ist.
Nur für die ist WiFi 7 wirklich eine sinnvolle Investition.
Gerade wenn man von Markenherstellern kauft, sind die Geräte ja echt nochmal einen Satz teurer als WiFi 6 Hardware.
Insbesondere dann, wenn die Antennenbestückung gut ist und die braucht man ja nun mal für hohe Datenraten.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr immer im Hinterkopf habt, dass diese ganzen Turbo-Erweiterungen und noch so teuren Router oder Mesh-Access-Points am Ende keine Garantie dafür geben,
dass ihr die hohen Datenraten auch wirklich im ganzen Haus oder in der ganzen Wohnung erreicht.
Elektromagnetische Wellen werden von der Umgebung stark beeinflusst.
Wenn ihr in einem Stahlbetonbau wohnt oder passionierter Schließfachsammler seid, dann kann es sein, dass von eurem 320 MHz breiten WiFi-7-Signal zwei Räume weiter nichts mehr über ist.
In so einer Situation hilft der teuerste Router nichts und ihr seid besser damit bedient, günstige WiFi-6-fähige Router und Repeater zu kaufen und letztere per Kabel zum Access-Point zu machen.
Pauschal kann man das leider selten beurteilen.
Wir wohnen ja alle zum Glück nicht in Standardgebäuden, aber das bedeutet auch, dass viel überschätzen und ausprobieren geht, wenn es darum geht,
WiFi-Passwörter pro Gerät zum Beste.
Ein gutes WLAN aufzubauen. Wir hoffen, euch hat das Video die Welt der neuen WLAN-Standards...
Ja, fand ich nicht schlecht. Hat er gut erklärt.
Reform der Nachrichtendienste. Was hat das...
Was haben die Nachrichtendienste mit Ärzten und Therapeuten zu tun?
Ach so. Okay, aber Nachrichtendienste?
Ne? Keine Ahnung.
Also, ich will gerade mal was gucken.
Weil die bestimmt mehr melden müssen, okay.
Der Gang zur Therapiestunde ist für die 25-Jährige Angelina Spitzig.
Sie kauft dabei auch die Möglichkeit vor, in geschützten Bereichen wie Arztpraxen oder Therapieräumen Informationen zu erheben.
Patienten wie Angelina Spitzig lehnen das ab.
Also ich war tatsächlich bewusst, dass das erste Mal gehört, dass man sich entsetzt.
Ja, wie jetzt?
Ja.
Ja, WTF?
Haben die komplett den Arsch offen, oder was?
Sind die komplett dem, natürlich Bundestagsabgeordneten, was?
Sind die komplett geistig hängen geblieben, oder was?
Ja, da muss halt der Therapeut demnächst auch noch geistiger sein.
Auf BR-Anfrage relativiert das Bundesinnenministerium diese Sorge.
Ärzte und Therapeuten seien keine spezifischen Aufklärungsziele.
Zudem komme ein Eingriff rechtlich nur bei qualifiziert gefährlichen Bedrohungen im Bereich.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
Und wer entscheidet, wann das der Fall ist?
Betracht.
Trotz der Ministeriumsaussagen will Angelina Spitzig die Debatte um den Gesetzentwurf weiter kritisch verfolgen.
Okay, und was genau haben die jetzt vor?
Spricht sie über ihre Depressionen, Ängste und Dinge, die sie sonst kaum jemandem erzählt.
Doch nun soll ein Gesetzentwurf den Nachrichtendiensten neue Befugnisse geben
und sie dabei auch die Möglichkeit vor, in geschützten Bereichen wie Arztpraxen oder Therapieräumen Informationen zu erheben.
Patienten wie Angelina Spitzig...
Alter, die sind ja dämlich.
Das ist echt richtig hängen geblieben.
Da kriege ich schon Zustände, wenn ich sowas wieder
lese.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Ist Linux secure?
Naja, wenn das Canonical sagt, dann wird das wohl so sein.
Linux ist nur secure, wenn es written in Rust ist.
Und Ubuntu hat ja mittlerweile die Core-Utils written in Rust.
Da kann ja nichts passieren.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Nach Hackerangriff auf Berlin hochsensible Daten veröffentlicht.
Na dann, zeig mal her.
Da habe ich ja vorher schon was zu gesagt.
Hast du eine Empfehlung für ein NAS, um Fotos zu sichern und Aufnahmen der Hauskameras zu speichern?
Da kannst du jedes x-beliebige NAS für benutzen.
also was ich
also was ich hier jetzt am Start
habe, wobei am Start haben ist zu viel
gesagt, ne, ich habe mehrere
Nasses hier und noch keins fertig eingerechnet
also ich habe immer noch meinen HP Microserver
mit ein paar Festplatten drin, ne
aber ich habe einmal hier einen Ugreen
DXP
RAW
ja
das habe ich am Start und dann habe ich noch
ein
Minisforum
N5R am Start.
So, haben alle
unterschiedliche Vorteile.
Was mich bei dem N5R
abfuckt ist, also 10
Gig haben sie alle.
Was mich bei dem N5R abfuckt
ist, dass die Netzwerkkarte
übel suckt
unter Linux.
Wenn man virtualisieren will, wohlgemerkt.
ja, aber
die Deluxe-Drival-Unterstützung ist wirklich
richtig für den Arsch.
Dafür hat das andere Vorteil, du hast hier
beispielsweise einen PCI-Express,
guck, du hast hier einen PCI-Express-
Anschluss und sowas,
das hast du,
du hast einen Oculink-Anschluss, du hast
einen PCI-Express-Anschluss, du hast einen
5-Gig-Netzwerk-Port, einen 10-Gig-Netzwerk-Port,
hier einen
PCI-Express-Anschluss, also das ist geil,
PC Express und interne NVMe-Anschlussmöglichkeiten.
Den PC Express hast du nicht.
Und eine ziemlich gute CPU ist hier drin.
Also von der Hardware ist das das bessere Gerät.
Brauchbare mobile Grafikkarte und eine ziemlich gute CPU.
Also hardwaremäßig ist das hier deutlich schlechter.
Aber die Netzwerkkarte ist besser.
So, das Ding ist, du kannst aber beide Nasses, sowohl das hier als auch das hier, vergiss, ganz ehrlich, vergiss die Software mit denen die ausgeliefert werden.
Würde ich beides nicht verwenden.
Du musst dir da selbst irgendwas drauf installieren.
Wenn du ein komplettes Fertigpaket haben willst, mit guter Software und Hardware, also naja, mit guter Software und der passenden Hardware dazu, kommst du eigentlich an so Dinge wie Synology nicht vorbei.
die dinger tun einfach auf der box das was sie sollen sein ology hat halt relativ teure
leistungsschwache hardware für den preis dafür ist dies ein ology software suites quasi mit
das umfassendste wasser die so daheim holen kannst wenn es denn brauchst hier musste dir
selbst was drauf installieren du kannst ja wenn du virtualisierung machen willst kannst den box
box drauf installieren kannst du denn schulers drauf installieren du kannst den android drauf
in 10 was ganz cool ist ja machen intern usb stecker für android android läuft ja gerne von
usb sticks wobei mittlerweile wohl auch von ssds du kannst ja auch noch media world oder irgendwas
drauf fahren aber dass das tut alles ja aber da musst du dich halt selbst um kümmern bei den wenn
du komplett paket haben willst dann dann sein ology ist ein mini pc genauso geeignet naja max
es ist keine absicht ich bin einfach nicht in der lage man zeugt richtig einzurichten hier
es ist ein mini also mini pcs kannst du auch verwenden ist halt die frage was du haben willst
wenn du jetzt also wenn du viel speicher haben willst ist mini pc vielleicht jetzt nicht das
beste in mini pc kriegst du maximal zwei nvme ssds rein also maximal aber mal
halbwegs erschwinglich vier terabyte also zweimal zwei terabyte ssds kannst du
mit 1 drüber machen falls du willst mach muss man ja auch nicht machen wenn du
externe backups hast musst du auch kein raid machen
vielleicht teilweise auch gar nicht so sinnvoll externe backups ist also backup
auf USB-Festplatte oder so gut ist.
Also wenn du mit den internen
NVMe-SSD-Steckplätzen
auskommst, kannst du auch einen Mini-PC nehmen.
Du kannst natürlich
auch, wenn du nicht so hohe Ansprüche
hast, wie viele
Festplatten und Storage du haben willst,
oder wie
zuverlässig das sein soll,
kannst du dir natürlich auch sagen,
ey, ich nehme einen Mini-PC,
baue mir da zwei
NVMe-SSDs ein
und mache noch
zwei USB-Festplatten dran oder so.
Das geht auch, das ist kein Problem.
Man muss sagen, USB-Festplatten sind
der reinen Lehre nach
natürlich ein bisschen
weniger zuverlässig als
fest eingebaute Festplatten. Allein schon,
weil du das Kabel einfach mal aus Versehen rausziehen kannst.
Und was Latenzen angeht,
USB
ein bisschen schwanken kann.
Also so für richtig
High-Performance-Reliable
Sachen ist jetzt
usb nicht das beste wenn du jetzt nicht so große große ansprüche hast wenn du einfach sagt ich
brauche irgendwas irgendeine netzwerkspeicher wo ich einmal in der woche meine backups drauf
speichern kann ja dann warum nicht macht ja nix mini pc 16 terabyte usb festplatte dran fertig
easy musste keine gedanken machen wobei muss halt sagen so viel platz ersparen ist gegen ein großes
nass ist es dann auch nicht weil du hast du mini pc und natürlich die externen usb festplatte die
je nachdem auch ein bisschen größer sein könnte wenn du allerdings da mehr also ich sag mal wenn
du mehr platten brauchst als was die internen vm e slots hergeben und mehr als 12 usb geräte dann
würde ich vielleicht doch eher auf so einem vorbett setzen wo du festplatten rein hängen
kannst über irgendeinen swap wechselrahmen weil weil sonst wird das wirklich sehr kabel
salat mäßig und dementsprechend auch fehleranfällig also ich du kannst natürlich ein mini pc nehmen
und da 8 usb externe usb festplatten anschließen das wird wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren
und du wirst damit nie Probleme haben.
Ich hätte da aber kein allzu gutes Gefühl dabei mit 8 USB-Festplatten.
Vor allem hat ein NAS auch LEDs, um die kaputten Platten anzuzeigen.
Kommt drauf an. Kommt drauf an, welche.
Kommt drauf an, welche.
Die hier haben beispielsweise LEDs, hier unten.
Da.
Und da.
Aber...
Meines Wissens nach können die nicht anzeigen, welche Platte kaputt ist.
Also das, es könnte sein, dass das Ugreen-NAS das kann, mit dem OS von Ugreen, dass das gemappt ist irgendwie, es kann sein.
Das Minis-Forum macht das meines Wissens nach gar nicht.
Das zeigt einfach nur Aktivität hier unten an, oder nicht.
Aber es gibt einen Treiber auf GitHub, um die LEDs anzusprechen aus Linux. Also wenn man das haben möchte, kann man das selbst bauen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es wahrscheinlich deutlich einfacher, sich einfach hier vorne ein Etikett draufzupappen mit der Seriennummer der Festplatte.
Wenn so ein kleiner Labelprinter hat oder einfach nur irgendeinen Zettel, wo du es draufschreibst.
Mit einem Labelprinter ist es natürlich noch viel besser.
Du drückst hier so einen kleinen Zettel aus und klebst den dran.
Klebst hier vorne einfach die Seriennummer der Festplatte dran.
Und dann siehst du ja in deinem Linux sofort, welche Festplatte kaputt gegangen ist und wo die drin ist steckt.
Da sehe ich jetzt wenig Nachteile gegenüber LEDs.
Cool ist es natürlich, wenn die LED anzeigt, wenn was kaputt ist.
Wenn du halt so ein All-in-One-Komplett-System haben willst, ist wahrscheinlich Synology am besten noch.
Aber wie gesagt, ich denke, du kommst auch, wenn du nicht...
Also komm, was hast du denn für Ansprüche, ja?
Zweimal für...
Wenn dir das ausreicht, kommst du damit bestimmt hin.
Was ich gucken würde bei alten Desktop-PCs, ist immer, wie es mit Stromverbrauch aussieht.
Also ich kann dir sagen, dass diese beiden Nasses hier relativ geringen Stromverbrauch haben.
Wenn du 10 Gig angeschlossen hast,
10 Gig verbraucht ja auch nochmal 2, 3, 4 Watt, je nachdem, wie du es anschließt.
Und du kommst, sag mal, du kommst so bei,
also einfach nur das System
mit einer SSD drin, um das System
zu booten, also
zwei SSDs drin, also drei
SSDs drin und das System
bootet ohne externe
Platte, die hochgefahren ist,
kommst du so auf
irgendwas, es schwankt zwischen
8 und 12
Watt Eidel.
Also das ist in Ordnung.
Du musst aber ein bisschen tunen im BIOS, dass das funktioniert.
Ja, kann man auch machen.
Also was ich probiert habe ist, ich habe die Netzwerkkarte aus meinem Minisforum PC.
Also die 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte, die benutze ich ja auf dem Host.
Und die wollte ich einbinden.
in der vm
und
die vms haben richtig
Probleme mit dem Netzwerktreiber.
Also mit dem Netzwerkkartentreiber,
der im Linux-Kernel ist, kriege ich von
10 Gig in der vm exakt 5 Gig
raus. Also da ist irgendwas kaputt.
Und mit dem Netzwerktreiber
des Herstellers habe ich andere Probleme.
Also die Netzwerkkarte fuckt mich ab.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, Leute.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es einen neuen Treiber gibt.
Was macht denn Realtek so?
Und wir hatten doch letztens was bei der Kernel-Mailing-Liste gefunden.
Ah ja, ja.
Bei der Kernel-Mailing-Liste gefunden, ob da...
Okay, da gucken wir gleich nochmal rein.
Also gibt es
einen neuen Treiber für die Netzwerkkarte hier?
Oh! Ne!
Die haben mich schon wieder verarscht.
Realtek.
Das ist Chat 11.16.
Das war das letzte Mal doch auch schon.
Da haben die uns das letzte Mal doch schon
gebetet mit 11.16.
11.16 kam im Februar raus.
Nicht am 3.7.
Die lügen einfach.
Die wissen einfach selbst nicht, was sie machen.
Wir haben sogar MD5 summt.
Den Treiber vom Februar
versus den Treiber angeblich vom
Juni, Juli.
Das ist ja genau der gleiche Treiber.
Die gebeten einfach richtig hart.
Die Leute von Realtek.
Okay, woher...
Ich habe bei der Kernel-Mailing-Liste immer so meine Probleme.
Ich habe da immer so meine Probleme zu erkennen.
Was da jetzt eigentlich schon gemerged ist und was nicht.
also das finde ich da finde ich das finde ich immer super kompliziert hier durch zu blicken
ich blick da nicht durch da können wir nicht so kann ich kann ich euch helfen
also hier gibt es neuen patch vom sogar vom dritten dritten neunten das ist noch nicht lange her
woher weiß ich denn jetzt also
woher weiß ich denn jetzt ob der kram
thank you for your contribution
also da ist noch nichts gemercht oder sonst hätte doch hier irgendjemand anderes außerdem
raven reingeschrieben wurde gepult oder nicht ich checkte es nicht ganz ehrlich
ich habe da echt meine probleme ich checke immer die die kölner mailing
nicht listen oder was da abgeht
das ist noch was anderes wieder
keine ahnung zumindest zumindest so wirklich gemerkt ist glaube ich noch nix
ja da wird sich bestimmt freuen wenn ich ihn anschreiben
Also gemerged ist hier noch nix, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich warte einfach ab.
Also ich wollte mir ja nochmal
einen Kernel bauen, wo diese Patches
drin sind, aber ich check es
einfach nicht.
Was ich mir da
überhaupt holen muss.
Guck mal, wir können da mal
net next
repo
hier
net next
Ne, wo ist denn das
offizielle net, hier, kernel
org
Das offizielle Repo
NetNext
Ah ja, ja
Wieder was anderes
Ich blick da nicht durch
Ich wollte gucken, ob es in Next drin ist.
Hier.
Das da.
Okay.
Repos.
Git clone.
Ach, exist.
Ich hab das schon mal geklont.
Git remote minus v.
Okay.
Git pull origin.
Main ist es jetzt ja, nicht mehr Master.
Ja, die X520, die habe ich tatsächlich ja auch noch eine rumliegen.
Was ich ein bisschen schade finde ist, dass die kein SREUV kann.
Die SREUV kann glaube ich erst die 720.
Das heißt, die würde ich der Sache bevorzugen,
Weil mit SREUV kannst du die Netzwerkkarte auf dem Host verwenden und in der VM, ohne dass du softwaremäßig irgendwas emulieren musst.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob hier irgendwas drin ist. Wie hieß der? Der Javen.
Da ist er, der Javen vom August.
Okay, da wurden anscheinend Sachen gemerged
Komm, Javen
Nach was muss ich suchen?
Ja
Da suchen wir mal danach.
4. September.
Das ist aber nicht der hier.
Das ist jetzt vom Juni?
Okay, also die sind anscheinend
Also die Patches sind anscheinend hier noch nicht drin
So müsste der Patch ja heißen
Dann eigentlich
Okay, ne, den gibt es hier anscheinend noch nicht
Okay
Whatever, wer soll da durchblicken, ey
Wo ist denn die Comet-ID?
Die gibt's nicht. Stimmt, die machen das ja alles über Patches irgendwie.
Mon KS, Alter. Ich find das so
Paints-Champ.
Aber ich kann nichts dagegen sagen.
Das funktioniert ja für Linux wohl ganz gut.
Ich find's aber krass undurchsichtig.
Naja.
Javen.
Der macht da irgendwas.
Welche anderen Sachen?
Okay, ne, die Patches sind noch nicht da drin.
Alles klar. So, gut.
Was können wir uns denn sonst noch angucken?
Genau, Hackerangriff auf Berlin.
Wer Zugang zum Darknet hat,
kann sich durch diese Ordnerstruktur
klicken. Dieses Video wurde uns
zugespielt und zeigt sie. Die über
1,4 Millionen...
Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum ist denn das geblurrt?
Das kannst du dir auf Twitter komplett unplört angucken.
Das wurde mir einfach in die Timeline gespült auf Twitter.
Da haben Leute einfach Screenshots von gepostet.
beispielsweise Notfallpläne in Gefahrensituationen oder Daten zur Trinkwassernotversorgung.
Ich bin sprachlos, dass man es schafft, geheimschutzrelevante Daten lapidar zu speichern und nicht abgeschottet abzusichern, so wie es die staatlichen Vorgaben sind.
Das lag garantiert auf irgendeinem Windows-Share. Man hat es ja auch anhand der Dateien gesehen.
Die Dateien, das waren irgendwelche, das waren, das meiste waren, das meiste waren Excel-Files. Das waren, das waren gefühlt alles irgendwelche Excel-Files.
Infrastrukturen entblößt, man hat Baupläne von Justizvollzugsanstalten jetzt öffentlich im Netz, man hat sogar die für einen Verteidigungsfall.
Die Passwörter waren alle 123 Amsterdam 1 oder irgendwie sowas.
Die haben ganz oft Amsterdam in den Passwörtern drin.
Habe ich gelesen.
Also wie gesagt, auf Twitter werden die Dinger, wenn ihr danach sucht, werden die Dinger im Klartext gepostet.
... kritische Infrastrukturen in Berlin auf einer Liste veröffentlicht.
Also Terroristen werden sich freuen.
Der Cyber-Sicherheitsexperte wirft dem Berliner Senat vor, grob fahrlässig gehandelt zu haben.
Der Regierende spricht von einem Angriff aufs Land.
Es ist eine sehr schwere Straftat gegen das Land.
Moment, das kann doch beides sein.
Es kann ein Angriff aufs Land sein, aber die können auch fahrlässig gerne.
Das eine schließt ja das andere nicht aus.
Berlin begangen worden.
Das LKA und die betroffenen Senatsverwaltungen werten nun mit Hochdruck die gestohlenen Daten aus.
Ach ja.
Wir werden die betroffenen Beschäftigten...
Techniker ist informiert.
...Dichten, Berlinerinnen und Berliner so schnell wie möglich informieren, beraten und unterstützen.
Wann das...
Der NSS 5-Leak, da habe ich gar nichts mehr mitgekriegt, passiert unklar.
Und auch wie groß das Ausmaß des wohl größten Datenklaus in Berlins Geschichte am Ende sein wird,
derzeit weiß das noch niemand.
Tja, aber es wird ja immer mehr bekannt.
Sebastian Schöbel ist bei mir aus unserer Politikredaktion.
Sebastian, ein paar Sachen hat der Herr Artug eben schon genannt.
Von den Dingen, die du gesehen hast, was sticht denn da am meisten raus?
Das ist eigentlich alles relevant, was man da finden kann.
Gerade die Daten zur kritischen Infrastruktur, zum Beispiel bei der Trinkwasserversorgung.
Das klingt jetzt erstmal irgendwie nicht ganz so schlimm, weil Trinkwasserbrunnen und so weiter, das kennt man vielleicht in Berlin, aber sowas ist für den Krisenfall extrem wichtig und darf nicht angegriffen werden.
Jetzt sind dazu Daten, Informationen, Berichte teilweise auch im Internet frei verfügbar. Das ist nicht gut, das gehört nicht in die Öffentlichkeit. Oder zum Beispiel Pläne zum Anbau beim Bundeskanzler.
Chat, wenn ihr solche Sachen seht, habt ihr dann auch nicht großes Vertrauen in das Speichern von Patientenakten und...
Chatverläufe und persönlichen Daten, die demnächst alle noch mehr abgezapft werden sollen.
Da hat man noch ein richtig gutes Gefühl, dass die Daten dort bei Experten richtig sicher und korrekt gelagert werden.
So etwas gehört mit Sicherheit nicht in die Öffentlichkeit, weil da sicherheitsrelevante Strukturen drin stecken.
Und dass das einfach so erbeutet werden konnte, das wirft tatsächlich Fragen auf.
Nun sind es eben nicht nur diese sicherheitsrelevanten Sachen, sondern tatsächlich auch persönliche Daten, gerade auch von Mitarbeitern der öffentlichen Verwaltung, sehr sensible Dinge. Was weiß man da?
Ja, das ist das eigentliche Drama hier, dass teilweise wirklich sehr persönliche Daten und Informationen von diesen Leuten, die in der Verwaltung arbeiten oder mit der Verwaltung gearbeitet haben, jetzt auch ebenfalls von diesen Hackern geklaut wurden.
Wir haben gehört, Geburtsurkunden sind zum Beispiel dabei oder der Scan von einer Geburtsurkunde von Kindern oder der Schwerbehindertenausweis von jemandem.
Aber auch Einschätzungen von Arbeitgebern über Mitarbeitende. So was möchte keiner von uns da draußen in der Öffentlichkeit.
Was?
Aber auch Einschätzungen von Arbeitgebern über Mitarbeitende.
Ah, also quasi das interne Performance Review.
Möchte keiner von uns da draußen in der Öffentlichkeit haben und das fliegt jetzt da draußen rum und keiner weiß, was damit passiert.
Die würden mich tatsächlich am meisten interessieren, wie die so performen.
Ich habe schon Leute aus der Verwaltung angeschrieben und gefragt, hey, könnt ihr mal meinen Namen googeln oder da in diesen Unterlagen suchen.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob von mir was mit dabei ist.
Du sagst schon, könnt ihr mal da googeln. Das heißt, das ist nicht so öffentlich, dass nun jeder einfach im Internet mal schnell gucken kann.
Nein, diese Daten liegen im Darknet. Da kommt man nur hin über verschlüsselte Wege, über spezielle Browser und auch diese Seite ist nicht so einfach aufzufinden.
Wenn man die dann gefunden hat, dauert es relativ lange überhaupt, in diese Daten reinzuschauen, weil auch der Datenupload relativ langsam dauert.
Ja, stimmt, Chad. Die haben doch bestimmt nichts zu verbergen, oder?
Warum haben die denn was dagegen, dass die Daten öffentlich im Internet sind?
Das verstehe ich nicht. Ich denke, wer nichts zu verbergen hat, hat damit der ganzen Sache auch kein Problem.
Oder?
Wie seht ihr das?
Relativ lange dauert. Das ist nicht ganz so einfach, aber die Daten können natürlich runtergezogen werden,
auf eine Festplatte zum Beispiel, und dann kann die jeder irgendwo mit hinnehmen.
Aber abschalten kann man diese Daten da im Darknet nicht, also nach dem Motto Gegenangriff machen.
Das ist in der Vergangenheit schon passiert, wenn es zum Beispiel darum ging,
im Darknet irgendwelche Online-Märkte für illegal Drogen zum Beispiel hochzunehmen
und die Täter dann zu versuchen zu finden.
Aber das ist extrem schwierig.
Funktioniert denn wenigstens das Krisenmensch-Bündnis?
Gegenangriff. Mal davon abgesehen, gehen wir mal davon aus,
das wäre so einfach möglich.
Wer bitte schon soll diesen Gegenangriff denn durchführen?
Was jetzt?
Ja, auch nur bedingt, auch da gibt es Kritik,
nicht nur aus der Opposition, was ja zu Wahlkampfzeiten normal ist.
Aber ich habe zum Beispiel heute, haben wir die Informationen vom RBB recherchiert,
dass in Lichtenberg sich große Sorgen gemacht wird,
ob diese Software, die da eingesetzt wird, um die Systeme jetzt zu checken und zu prüfen,
dass die selbst eine ziemlich mächtige Überwachungssoftware ist.
Und die möchte man eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt im eigenen System haben.
Da gibt es im Hintergrund eine Menge Diskussionen darüber,
ob man sich da nicht mit dieser US-Firma eventuell das nächste Problem schafft.
Und so geht die Diskussion wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten auch immer noch weiter.
Also das zeigt auch wieder, dass Aufräumen nach so einem Hackerangriff bringt weitere Probleme mit sich.
Die elektronische Patientenakte ist sicher, genau.
Das ist auch eines der ersten Sachen, die ich mir gerade gedacht habe.
Wir pausieren die Kommentare über Nacht.
Warum?
Komm uns ab, Post.
Warum müssen die eigentlich alles moderieren?
Warum können die Leute nicht einfach mal posten lassen?
Ah, verstehe, das muss ja alles immer korrekt eingeordnet werden.
Jaja.
Einordnen ist für mich so das Unwort 2026 gewordene.
Take 5090.
Dieser RTX-Betrug ist höchstpreis China-Kupfer-Update.
Ja, aua.
Tierheime haben keinen Platz mehr.
Sad girl.
Das Tierheim Bayreuth hat noch nicht lange geöffnet und schon kommen die ersten, die ein Tier geöffnet haben.
Hardcore auf den Sack.
Mal gucken, wie das hier ist.
Es ist leider eine Müdigkeit am Steuer.
Die Augen fallen für Sekunden zu.
Das geht ja noch.
Das ist ja noch in Ordnung, ja.
Was ist noch?
7 self-hosted Apps, die wir wirklich brauchen.
Wir gucken das Video nicht.
Wir skippen da jetzt mal.
Was brauchen wir denn?
Book Orbit.
Nein, das brauche ich bestimmt nicht.
Elmchat.
Brauche ich bestimmt auch nicht.
Jellydash brauche ich auch nicht.
Sekuru.
Äh, was soll das sein?
Irgend so eine Finanzplanungs-App brauche ich auch nicht.
HA Proxy Manager habe ich schon.
Lan Orang-Utan.
What?
Was für ein Ding?
Lan Orang Utan.
Lightweight Network.
Ach, Network.
Ja, okay.
Also im Endeffekt kannst du damit dein Netzwerk scannen lassen.
Und dir anzeigen lassen, was du da für eine...
Ach.
Okay.
Ja, das könnte eventuell nützlich sein, aber naja.
Adventure-Log brauch ich auch nicht.
Okay, bam, hätten wir das schon mal abgehakt.
Brauchen das nicht.
Alter, die wollen echt unbedingt, dass ich mir angucke, dass Sarah zu viel trinkt.
Der Nico!
Gibt's ja auch noch.
Die Empfehlungen sind wieder echt painstrap.
Was haben wir denn?
Morpheus hat ein Video gemacht.
Die wahre Macht von Linux.
Okay, ich hab mir gedacht,
19 Minuten Morpheus Video,
das geht ja. Also ich guck die Videos
echt gerne, aber die sind meistens viel zu lang
für den Stream.
My network was destroyed.
Okay, zeig mal her, was ist da los?
Okay, lass mich raten, das ist halb so wild, wie es im Intro aussieht.
Alter, ist ja gut.
Reg dich ab.
Das Video ist mir schon fast zu hyperaktiv.
Stimmt, warum ist er so hyped? Weil sein Netzwerk kaputt ist.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht, sondern es eignet sich einfach nur gut für ein Video.
Oh, Spannung.
Okay, das könnte ja ein durchaus interessantes Video sein, aber das ist mir zu hyperaktiv, ey.
Guck mal, guck mal das lieber Morpheus an, das ist immer entspannter.
Schau mal, das hier ist mein Linux gewesen bis letzte Woche und das ist das Neue.
Das ist immer noch mein System.
Okay, das sieht ja grausam aus.
PDF.
System, aber eben mit einem neuen Theme, meinem eigenen Persona 5.
Ah, daran erinnert mich, das stimmt, ja.
...inspirierten System mit eigenem aktiven Fenster...
Alter, das kann man doch nicht benutzen!
Das ist ja... Alter!
Da tut dir ja alles weh, wenn du da länger als eine Viertelstunde drauf guckst.
...eigenen Widgets und sogar komplett eigenem Startmenü.
Nicht wundern, ich habe hier auf Wissenschaftler gesetzt anstatt auf Persona 5 Charaktere,
weil copyright und so denn immerhin könnt ihr das hier auch auf github einfach runterladen und
selber das weib koden lassen aber jetzt benutzen ja was ist eigentlich passiert ich bin ehrlich
ich brauchte eine auszeit ich habe aktuell einfach keine lust mehr immer nur über probleme zu reden
gegen die wir ankämpfen sollen müssen verstehe ich habe ich mich einfach mal es läuft so viel
scheiße gerade was it und security angeht und irgendwelche gesetzespläne dazu und dann kann
man es kann sich eigentlich jeden tag über was neues aufregen kann ich voll voll nachvollziehen
setzen mir egoistischerweise mein eigenes linux system einfach hübsch gemacht ich weiß hübsch
liegt heftig im auge des betrachters ich könnte mir vorstellen viele von euch werden das absolut
grauenhaft finden aber das ist die eigentliche schönheit von linux systemen denn ihr seid nicht
gezwungen euch von irgendwas limitieren zu lassen der desktop ist in linux halt
einfach nur eine empfehlung ja man kann verwenden was man will wenn man dann kann
also ich meine unter wayland ist die auswahl jetzt
immer ganz so groß von den großen desktops kannst du im prinzip eh nur kde verwenden
weil gnome suckt und gnome überhaupt nicht customizable ist
oder sagen wir mal
definitiv nicht so
customizable ist wie KDE.
Du kannst dafür komplett
abdrehen,
wenn du so Sachen wie Niri verwendest
oder Hyperland.
Da kannst du mega krass customizen.
Da musst du aber auch customizen.
Da musst du ja eh alles selbst bauen.
Und darum geht
es heute. Oh, und vielleicht
doch eine kleine News aus der echten Welt,
hab ich sogar auch noch für euch, es muss ja trotzdem irgendwie
ein Morpheus-Video bleiben. Microsoft
feiert sich dieses Jahr in ihrem
Insider-Blog dafür, dass man
die Taskleiste bald wieder an
den Rand des Greenschiebens... Oh mein Gott!
Microsoft!
Habt ihr nach drei Monaten
Chat-GPT prompten,
was gefunden, was funktioniert, ja?
Ich zitiere
One of the most requested features.
Das finde ich besonders geil, weil das alles unter Windows 10 natürlich schon easy ging.
Das ging unter Windows 98, by the way.
Auch schon.
Das hat man aber verschlimmbessert, indem man...
By the way, Chat, ich weiß nicht, ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es wusstet.
Die Taskleiste hier, ne?
Das ist eine React-Anwendung.
Das ist kein Native Win32
Bla Dings Gedöns
Oder auch kein WinUI in dem Sinn
Das ist eine React Anwendung
Und jetzt wo ihr das wisst
Leuchtet vielleicht auch ein
Warum die sich so scheiße anfühlt
Und Linux nicht mal vorgibt
Wie viele Taskleisten du haben kannst
Wenn du Bock hast, gönn dir halt auf
jedem deiner fünf Bildschirme an jeder der vier Ecken mindestens eine Taskleiste.
Gönn dir.
Aber fangen wir vorne an.
Der Desktop.
Linux an sich hat nicht einen Desktop.
Bei Microsoft kennt ihr es als Explorer.
Bei Linux gibt es viele davon.
Das macht die Auswahl ehrlich gesagt anfangs etwas schwer.
Aber auch diese Desktops...
Ah, ich wollte gerade nochmal was anderes gucken, damit ich das WLAN...
Wir haben uns doch eben das WLAN, dieses WLAN-Video angeguckt.
Ich wollte mal schauen, bevor wir das jetzt weitergucken.
Ich wollte mal schauen, was aktuelle Access Points, wenn ich mir neue Access Points kaufen würde.
Wer zum Teufel ist Belden, Alter?
Belden? Keine Ahnung.
Netzwerk, WLAN-Controller.
Ich wollte mal gerade gucken, was neue Access Points von denen kosten.
Wo sieht man denn die Access Points?
Produkte?
Ach, Wireless-Zugangspunkte.
MonkaS, Alter.
Okay, R670 ist wohl der neue.
Okay, haltet euch jetzt fest.
Haltet euch fest.
Scheiße, Mann.
Ein Access Point.
1200 Euro.
Schnapper, oder?
Schauen wir mal gerade,
wie es da bei Ebay aussieht,
ob es da vielleicht die älteren mittlerweile gibt.
Also, die hier gibt es,
warte mal, was ist denn die 700er Serie?
Gerade mal, wenn wir hier dabei sind.
Oh, guck mal,
guck mal, die haben schon BE.
Haben wir nicht gelernt, dass BE Wi-Fi 8 ist oder so?
Gibt es die 700er nicht mehr?
Doch, hier 770.
700.
Brauche ich nicht.
Ah, nee, das war BN.
Das ist teuer.
Okay, R620.
Gucken wir mal.
Wie sieht es da preislich so aus?
Gucken wir mal an den R550.
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Und der Preis geht auch halbwegs klar.
Das ist der Nachfolger von denen.
Das sind die WiFi 6.
Die Dinger sind extrem hässlich.
Oh ja.
Ich bin dann aus Wechselpoints.
Also ich habe hier im Wohnzimmer
den hier hängen.
Ich habe mich verguckt.
Das ist gar kein WiFi.
Ich habe den hier im Wohnzimmer hängen.
An der Decke.
So, wir gucken jetzt einfach mal nach.
650 gibt es hier.
Also 650 sind die WiFi 6.
Das wäre zumindest ein kleines Upgrade.
Über meinen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das Upgrade ist mir nicht groß genug.
Gucken wir mal lieber, was ein R670 kostet.
Oder R660 oder so, weiß ich nicht, was es da gibt.
Also die Dinger sind selbst gebraucht, nicht billig.
Gibt es nicht.
Gibt es ein R570 vielleicht?
Weil das sind die Wi-Fi 7 Dinger.
wir können aber auch einfach mal hier sagen
Access Point
und jetzt hier unten
WLAN-Standard, gab es doch hier irgendwo.
Äh.
Habe ich hier nicht irgendwo
vorhin irgendwo WLAN-Standard gesehen?
Ne?
Gab es das nicht?
gibt es nicht mehr.
Ach, hier.
Ne, das sind ja die ganz alten.
A, C, A, X.
A, X ist
WiFi 6, ne?
Das Upgrade
lohnt sich nicht.
Also, die Dinger,
Ihr habt es ja gesehen, die Dinger werden halt brutal teuer, wenn ich mir die neue kaufe.
Deswegen warte ich noch ein paar Jahre.
Und dann kann ich auf die Wi-Fi 6 Geräte upgraden.
Und kriege die günstig bei Ebay.
Weil das ist preislich halt echt absolut Kackel.
Jetzt kommen wir Morpheus weiter.
Kommen halt alle nur mit ihren Empfehlungen und Grundeinstellungen.
Ich fang mal vorne an. Mein erstes Linux war, ich meine so 2013 oder 2014, ein Linux Mint.
Das war auch...
Was war mein erstes Linux? Lass mal überlegen.
Suse.
2002 oder so. Suse Linux auf so blauen CDs.
Aber damals konnte ich damit überhaupt nichts anfangen.
Mein erstes richtig ernsthafte Auseinandersetzen mit Linux war glaube ich Debian damals.
Ich hatte davor ein paar Linux-basierte, so einen Linux-basierten lokalen Router.
Gab es damals IPCop hieß das.
hab ich mal ein bisschen mit rum
experimentiert, aber da musstest du nicht viel
Linux-technisch machen.
Ich glaub, das erste, womit
ich mich wirklich auseinandergesetzt hab, war, glaub ich, Debian.
Debian Edge
war das, glaub ich.
Debian Edge, da kann ich mich nämlich
noch dran erinnern, weil das war
gerade in der Beta-Phase.
Davor gab's Sarge.
Das hab ich dann...
Damit hab ich mich nicht groß auseinandergesetzt.
Patrick, dankeschön.
Massive Subscription.
Danke für den Sub.
Xubuntu mit Unity.
Xubuntu war mit XFCE.
Hier, guck mal. Edge.
Ah, nee.
Davor war Sarge. Genau.
Davor war Sarge.
Also, damit habe ich angefangen.
Ich habe mir einmal Sarge installiert.
Dann habe ich festgestellt, aha.
Es gibt jetzt auch schon eine Beta von Edge.
Und
damit habe ich dann so wirklich angefangen, mich mit Linux
zu beschäftigen.
Damals wurde zwischen Sarge und Edge
wurde der X-Server ausgetauscht.
Da wurde
von X-Free zu
X-Org gewechselt. Hier, vor Edge
gab es noch keinen X-Org.
Also so lange ist das schon her.
Also hier so habe ich angefangen,
mich mit Linux auseinanderzusetzen.
Als Edge in der Beta
war. Also, also
wahrscheinlich
irgendwann 2006 oder so.
Würde ich mal vermuten.
Das heißt, ich mach das jetzt 20 Jahre.
Genau. Bam.
Das, was ich dann meiner Mom
ein paar Jahre später installiert hab und
vielen Umsteigern von Windows empfehle ich
es noch. Linux Mint ist die Distribution.
Das heißt, da hat jemand... Linux Mint
ist nicht verkehrt. Den Linux
Kran übernommen und dann noch ein paar andere Sachen
so zusammengeklatscht, dass es für uns
ein voll funktionables System
ist, mit Fenstern, mit installierbarem
Programm, mit einfach allem drumherum.
Und dazu braucht es natürlich
auch eine Desktop-Oberfläche
und die wiederum heißt bei
Linux Mint Cinnamon.
Also wie Zimt. Sie ist extrem
ähnlich zu Windows. Ihr habt eine
Taskleiste, ihr habt ein Startmenü, ihr habt Fenster,
ihr habt Desktop-Icons. Das ist jetzt
nichts Besonderes, aber genau so soll
es halt sein. Ich habe mich mal mit jemandem von euch
auf Instagram darüber unterhalten und der meinte
Was mittlerweile wohl auch echt gut sein muss, hören sagen,
habe ich lange nicht mehr selbst benutzt,
Fedora soll mittlerweile wohl wirklich echt brauchbar sein als Desktop-Betriebssystem.
Nachdem Ubuntu auf dem Desktop ja immer weniger Rolle spielt,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das echt ganz, ganz brauchbar ist.
Also ich bin ja mittlerweile hier auf CacheOS gelandet.
das liegt aber daran weil ich die ganze zeit schon auf archi lux war und ich
mein mini pc wieder mit archi lux installieren wollte und da habe ich mir
gedacht ach probier doch einfach mal cache us aus da hast du halt ein ordentlich
vorkonfiguriertes kde unter deinem archi lux
installiert funktioniert seitdem habe ich es drauf
Cinnamon ist halt langweilig, aber im positiven Sinn.
Und man kann Cinnamon sogar auch mit Cinnamon Spices anpassen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele ihren Zimt mit Gewürzen speisen, aber ihr könnt.
Aber grundsätzlich ist Cinnamon mir über die Jahre deswegen ein bisschen zu langweilig geworden.
Es ist weniger Cutting Edge, also weniger die neuesten Patches.
Und es hat eben deutlich weniger Anpassungsfunktionen.
Wo wir gerade bei der alten Zeit sind, ein kurzer Einschub aus meinem alten Job.
Als Pentester habe ich Passwörter fast nie geknackt.
Das musste ich auch tatsächlich einfach nicht.
Wenn ihr euch irgendwo einloggt, dann merkt sich die Seite...
Ah, Sellout. Sellout-Modus, oder?
... das nämlich in einem sogenannten Session-Cookie.
Einer kleinen Datei, die ab da als euer Ausweis gilt.
Wer die klauen kann, ist quasi als ihr eingeloggt.
Ohne Passwort, ohne zwei Faktor.
Das ist bestimmt Sellout-Modus.
Die Anmeldung ist ja längst passiert.
Und genau deshalb werden gestohlene Cookies im Dark Web massenweise gehandelt.
NordVPN, der Sponsor dieses Videos, hat dagegen jetzt was, was ich tatsächlich sehr elegant finde.
Der Antivirus der neuesten Generation, wie sie ihn nun genannt haben,
weil die Betreuungssituation heute halt eine ganz andere ist wie vor noch 15 Jahren,
checkt kontinuierlich, ob eure Login-Cookies im Dark Web zum Verkauf stehen und schlägt...
Das heißt aber auch, erstes Mal muss das Ding noch selbst meine Login-Cookies irgendwie abgreifen, um es dann suchen zu können.
Oder?
Will ich das denn?
Sofort Alarm, wenn eure dabei sind.
Abgeglichen wird gegen eine Datenbank mit 130 Milliarden Darknet-Cookies.
Übermittelt wird dabei aber immer nur eine teilweise gehashte Version.
Also ein kryptografischer Fingerabdruck und niemals euer eigener Cookie im Klartest.
Das funktioniert aktuell für die 20 gängigsten Websites von YouTube über Amazon bis hin zu GitHub.
Kommt die Warnung, dann wisst ihr sofort Bescheid.
Also ihr müsst die Sitzung beenden und sofort euer Passwort ändern.
Und der geklaute Keks ist danach tatsächlich für den Angreifer wertlos.
Und das ist genau richtig.
Wenn ihr das haben wollt, nordvpn.com.
Wenn du schnell genug bist.
Der Link ist in der Beschreibung und hier natürlich auch neben mir als QR-Code wie immer verlinkt.
Da gibt es gerade einen großen Rabatt plus vier Bonusmonate auf den Zwei-Jahres-Plan.
Und damit zurück zum Thema.
Nachdem man diese Anfangsphase mit Linux hinter sich hat und sich vielleicht ein bisschen eingewöhnt hat,
fängt für gewöhnlich bei den motivierteren Bezirken das Distro-Hopping an.
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt auch.
Das Distro-Gehoppe...
Wobei ich da nie so richtig davon betroffen war, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich habe nicht groß Distro gehoppt.
Auf dem Server habe ich lange Debian verwendet.
Beruflich Red Hat, beziehungsweise CentOS.
Weil die so geil waren für Lizenzen.
Dann habe ich irgendwann, bin ich dazu übergegangen,
auf dem Server Ubuntu Server zu verwenden.
Und dann hat mich Ubuntu abgefuckt und ich verwende wieder Debian.
Privat.
Und für Gebastel.
Für alles, was ich nicht beruflich mache.
Ja, so. Und auf dem Desktop? Leute, habt ihr auf dem Desktop irgendwas anderes von mir schon mal als Archlinux gesehen? Ich glaube nicht. Seit ich, zumindest seit ich auf Twitch bin, ist es immer Archlinux. Ne, Manjaro. Okay, es war Manjaro vorher. Ich geb's zu, es war Manjaro, aber, aber, ich gehe so weit und sage, Manjaro ist ja fast ein Archlinux.
Casual S ist auch ein Arch-Distro.
Also, ich hab nie so richtig
krass Distro gehoppt.
Ich hab seit Ewigkeiten
Arch auf dem Desktop, Debian auf dem Server
im professionellen Umfeld, irgendwas Red Hat-mäßiges.
Am Gentoo
würde ich gar nicht erst anfangen.
Also,
wirklich viel ist da nicht.
Probiert also
andere Distributionen.
Nix OS ist auch nix, was ich auf dem Desktop
verwenden würde.
Wir haben tatsächlich auf der Arbeit jetzt eine Workstation, die ist gar nicht so unähnlich zu NixOS. Es benutzt nicht NixOS, aber es hat einen ähnlichen Gedanken von NixOS. Und zwar, wir bekommen eine Linux-Workstation auf der Arbeit, die wird immer einmal am Tag neu, nachts neu aufgebaut.
Da wird man sich denken, ja gut, und jetzt?
Dann ist ja immer alles weg.
Naja, das System wird neu aufgebaut, dein Heimatverzeichnis bleibt bestehen.
Und nach dem Neuaufbau wird ein Skript ausgeführt, was in deinem Heimatverzeichnis liegt,
mit dem du Sachen wieder einrichten kannst.
Das heißt, du musst wirklich deine VM so aufbauen, dass sie reproduzierbar neu aufbaubar ist.
Das ist an sich gar nicht so schwer. Ich meine, du brauchst ein paar Upgate-Installs, ein paar Sets über Dateien drüber und so fertig. Das sind dann im Endeffekt vielleicht 30, 40 Zeilen und gut ist. Und du hast halt immer ein top aktuelles, nightly aktuell gepatchtes System am Start.
Workstation gleich Arbeits-PC, Cloud-Arbeits-PC
die Linux-Kiste, auf der ich Root-Rechte habe und alles machen kann, was ich will
ich meine, ich habe auf unseren Servern auch Root-Rechte
aber halt Workstation, wo ich was dran arbeite
da habe ich auch einen XFCE-Desktop drauf, der im Endeffekt
mehr oder weniger fast genauso aussieht, wie mein Cache-OS-Desktop
sowas wie Ubuntu oder
Was hältst du von ein paar Distro-Hopping-Streams?
Das wäre, also ja,
das wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt,
sich das anzugucken,
aber ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich halt nicht umsteigen werde.
Ist das alles selbst geschrieben?
Nee, die verwenden irgendwas,
irgendwas in der Google Cloud
verwenden die für diese Workstations.
ich bin aber sehr zufrieden jetzt ich habe das die letzte woche über also das
ist ja das ist ja neu dass wir so ein ding als da bestellt habe die letzte
woche über verwendet das funktioniert wirklich super weil im endeffekt habe
ich halt einen vollwertigen linux desktop jetzt bei mir auf der arbeit so
hier sieht ähnlich aus wie hier und das ist halt sehr nice und ich muss mich
weniger mit windows geschiss rumschlagen
Braucht man nicht.
Ich sehe den Sinn von Omachi nicht.
Man kann sich einfach ein Arch oder ein Cache.us installieren und dann selbst einrichten.
Letztendlich ist ein Omachi ja, wenn es das noch so ist,
ist es quasi ein Arch-Linux mit so einem Customized-Menü.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich wüsste halt noch nicht mal zu was ich hoppen sollte.
Was könnten wir zum Beispiel damit ausprobieren?
Wir können uns, okay, eine Sache, die mir einfällt,
wir könnten mal aktuelles Fedora ausprobieren.
Das finde ich tatsächlich gar nicht verkehrt, ein aktuelles Fedora.
Weil ich höre immer, dass ein aktuelles Fedora nicht verkehrt sein soll.
Das Ding ist nur, worauf installiere ich das?
VM? VM sackt halt mit Wayland komplett rein.
Ich bräuchte noch einen zweiten Mini-PC für sowas.
Aber dann ist die Frage, wie filme ich das?
Ich habe ja nur eine Capture-Karte für den anderen Mini-PC.
Auf dem NAS könnte ich es installieren.
Das stimmt.
auf dem Minis-Forum NAS könnte ich es installieren.
Das hat einen ziemlich starken
8-Kern-Ryzen und eine halbwegs brauchbare mobile
Radeon-Grafikkarte. Das ist gar nicht verkehrt.
Ich könnte tatsächlich auf dem NAS installieren.
Und dann schließen wir einfach die KVM an.
NAS plus KVM und über die KVM
bedienen wir das dann. Ja, das könnte man machen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das können wir ausprobieren.
Exzellent.
Auch schon wieder Content.
Jetzt gucken wir uns aber an, was der Morpheus hier treibt.
Weil irgendwie ist halt das Gras auf der anderen Seite immer ein bisschen grüner.
Ich habe da auch tatsächlich...
Zumindest wenn die Leute dann eine Distro gefunden haben,
ist das nächste, es wird richtig hart customised.
Habe ich ja auch gemacht.
Also ich sage mal so, hier guckt mal.
mein alter
Streaming-PC
oder alte Streaming-Workstation,
die war ja auch
sehr customized.
Ich kann es gerade nochmal zeigen.
Habe ich jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr angehabt,
weil ich jetzt auf dem
CacheOS Mini-PC bin.
Weil
vor allem noch mit X
mach mal ein Update
ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist
ja, guck, das ist ein
Custommeister
i3 Desktop gewesen hier
das ist ein i3 Desktop
mit, ja, allem was man eigentlich
so braucht, ne
war halt, auch hier das Menü
und so alles komplett customised.
Excellent. Emoji-Menü.
Clipboard, Copy-Paste.
Das fand ich nicht schlecht.
Habe ich gerne benutzt.
Aber ihr werdet vielleicht sehen,
ups, jetzt
backt es hier rum. Ihr werdet vielleicht sehen,
dass mein Cache-OS
sehr ähnlich aussieht.
Hier oben, wie beim Tiling Window Manager, die 1, 2, 3, 4 Desktops.
Mehr habe ich ja hier auch nicht.
Guck, 1, 2, 3, 4. Ich habe sogar nur 3 belegt hier.
Also 1, 2, 3. Hier am ersten Browser Fullscreen,
am zweiten Terminal Fullscreen, gleicher Terminal Config.
Also da ist gar nicht viel Unterschied zwischen dem Tiling Window Manager und dem hier.
Guck mal, sogar die Anzeige von, sogar die Anzeige hier oben habe ich.
Ich habe die gleiche, das gleiche Shortcut für Application Launch Menü, gleiche Shortcut für Clipboard Manager.
Ja, und guck, sogar hier oben diese Anzeige, CPU Auslastung ist hier relativ ähnlich.
Also, tja, mach das mal wieder aus.
Ich benutze im Prinzip mein Cache-US, was wäre Power of, mein Cache-US mehr oder weniger wie meinen alten Tiling-Menu-Manager.
Warum ich das nicht mehr benutze? Weil ich jetzt Linux-Mini-PC benutze und nicht mehr die VM.
Und auf dem Linux-Mini-PC wollte ich halt was Neues mit Wayland verwenden, als Wayland-Basis,
weil X auch immer weiter ausgefaced wird über die nächsten Jahre von allen möglichen Distributionen.
dachte ich mir, wir setzen auch gleich mal auf was Neues
und dann bin ich halt bei CacheOS gelandet
mit dem Default Debian, weil das
ganz gut vorinstalliert ist
und ich finde, es ist auch wirklich
es hat auch ein paar
gute Ideen, CacheOS
was ich zum Beispiel wirklich nice finde ist
wenn man jetzt, sagen wir mal
ähm
nicht jam, lul
wir installieren jetzt mal irgendwas hier, Btop
oder so, irgendein Kack, den ich sonst nicht brauche
ja, hier Btop
installiere ich, zack
und guck, der macht einen Snapshot
bevor er installiert, das heißt, wenn
jetzt ein Systemupgrade
komplett
mein System zerschießt
kann ich immer noch Snapshots
im Bootmenü zurückrollen
das finde ich, das ist wirklich gut durchdacht
was sie hier gebaut haben, standardmäßig
finde ich eigentlich ganz gut
Ja, das hier braucht kein Mensch.
Es ist unter Wayland einiges problematisch.
Auch Automatisierungen sind unter Wayland nicht so ohne weiteres möglich.
Also Wayland hat schon noch einige Lücken.
Es gibt auch keine gescheiten RDP-Server.
oder VNC, oder generell Remote-Möglichkeiten.
Das Beste, was ich bisher entdeckt habe, ist,
man kann das Ganze über Moonlight und Sunshine,
oder wie das heißt, machen, aber das hat auch seine Probleme.
Ja, so, wie gesagt, seitdem bin ich hier,
bei meinem CacheOS habe ich außer den Hintergrund,
der ab und zu wechselt, habe ich unter CacheOS
gar nicht so viel customised.
Das kommt default.
Ganz gut
eingestellt daher.
Aber jetzt gucken wir mal weiter, was der Morpheus so treibt.
Über die Jahre
durchaus eine Reise hinter mir.
Ubuntu, Kali, Arch Linux
und mal ein paar...
Kali wäre ich glaube ich nie auf die Idee
gekommen, das als Daily Desktop zu verwenden.
Ich länger als nur ein paar Monate hatte und jetzt bin ich bei NixOS hängen geblieben.
Oh, ein NixOS User.
Da würde mich tatsächlich mal sein Setup interessieren.
Davon kommt entweder von Haus aus mit seinem eigenen Desktop bzw. Fenstermanager und allem.
Oder ihr entscheidet, welchen ihr selber haben wollt.
Ihr könnt einen anderen Desktop...
Was ist Kali? Kali ist eine Distribution auf, ich glaube, Debian Basis.
Zumindest benutzen die Apt als Package Manager, wo alle möglichen Security Tools, Pen Testing Tools und sowas vorinstalliert kommt.
Du hast Man in the Middle Proxy, du hast Aircrack und so Gedöns dabei.
Ganz einfach wie jedes andere Paket installieren, dann habt ihr ihn einfach bei der Anmeldung einfach so zur Auswahl.
Bei mir sah das tatsächlich zeitweilig so aus, dass ich mich als Morpheus unter fünf verschiedenen Desktop-Oberflächen anmelden konnte.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel neben Xenamon noch XFCE, eine möglichst minimale Konten.
Den?
Da gibt es zum Beispiel neben...
Den habe ich auf der Arbeit.
Weil wie gesagt, die Kiste, die Workstation ist ja noch auf X.
Da habe ich XFCE.
Weil sich das Remote auch leichtgewichtig schön bedienen lässt.
XFCE, eine möglichst minimalistische Oberfläche mit weniger Schnickschnack und Animation.
Ich bin da der Meinung, das spricht bei nicht XFCE, sondern XFCE.
Also ich finde XFCE ist die viel bessere Betonung.
Wenn man mal ein bisschen minimalistischer unterwegs sein möchte, das kann aber auch vor allem wirklich praktisch sein für ältere oder schwächere Hardware.
Wie sagen eigentlich die Amis dazu? XFCE oder so?
Ein sehr alter Laptop.
Dann gibt es GNOME, das für einen Windows-Umsteiger wahrscheinlich auf die größte Höhe...
Gnome ist Schrott.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Er hat ein Video über sein NixOS?
Echt?
Wahrscheinlich so ein halbe Stunde Video, was ich schlecht im Stream gucken kann.
Hat er hier NixOS?
Das hier?
Also Gnome kann ich überhaupt nicht ab.
Weil die Philosophie hier ist, dass der Desktop bitte weg sein soll und eigentlich eh nur im Weg ist.
Das Startmenü hier ist tatsächlich erstmal Fullscreen, aber wenn man was eingetippt hat, dann ist es danach auch wieder weg.
Das Ganze ist eher MacOS-artig und Workflow-first, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Aber ich war nie so richtig Fan davon.
Macht ihn mir weiterhin sehr sympathisch.
Ich mag Gnome auch nicht.
Als Gegenströmung gab es dann aber auch Maid mit der tatsächlich lustigen Entstehungsgeschichte.
Ja, Maid war ein Gnome 2 Fork, glaube ich.
Die Fortführung von Gnome 2.
Nachdem das offizielle Gnome 3 einfach alles einmal zu sehr geändert hat und das andere einfach zu viel Änderung auf einmal war.
Das ist sozusagen für die...
Gnome ist polished. Das stimmt.
Also man muss sagen, die Gnome-Leute, wenn die was einbauen, dann bauen sie es richtig ein.
Richtig bedeutet nach ihrer Philosophie.
Wenn einem allerdings diese Gnome-Philosophie nicht gefällt, hast du halt gelitten.
Du kannst Gnome, du musst es halt so benutzen, wie es gedacht ist.
Wusstest du, dass Gnome standardmäßig nicht mal einen Minimieren-Button im Fenster hat?
Das ist bloated, das braucht man nicht.
Gut, ich brauche das wirklich nicht.
Weil ich Multiple Desktops mit Fullscreen-Anwendungen verwende.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, viele Leute mögen das standardmäßig, einen minimierten Knopf zu haben.
2010er Linux Kids.
Und natürlich ist da auch noch Cosmic.
Monka S. Monka Toss, Toss, Toss.
Aber auch tatsächlich ein echt toller Desktop.
Das Ganze ist extrem Wayland First und sehr modern mit Tiling, da komme ich nachher noch dazu.
Und natürlich KDE Plasma.
Und bei letzteren bin ich tatsächlich mit meinem aktuellen Nix so erst mal hängen geblieben.
KDE Plasma ist vom Look and Feel...
Also, Leute, ich bin auch der Meinung,
neben Tiling Window Managern, wenn man Bock hat, es zu customizen,
ist KDE der einzig benutzbare,
vollumfängliche, wie soll man sagen,
so ausgereifte Linux-Desktop, den es gibt.
Das ist aus meiner Sicht, ja.
Windows auf Steroiden, wenn ihr so wollt.
Es will einfach alles können und alles anpassbar haben.
Und fuck, ich hab das das erste Mal seit Anfang des Jahres und bin...
Ja, Cinnamon könnte man sagen, ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Das benutzt mein Vater schon seit ein paar Jahren jetzt und hat keine Probleme.
So schlimmer Fanboy geworden.
Did you know? KDE ist eigentlich die Community.
Plasma ist der Desktop-Community deshalb, weil KDE buchstäblich ein eingetragener Verein mit Sitz in Berlin ist.
Gegründet übrigens von Matthias und Matthias.
Eins der Board-Member war bis letztes Jahr Groot.
Plasma hingegen ist extrem modular.
Im Zentrum läuft K-Win, das ist der Window-Manager.
Das Ding, um Fenster zu verschieben, also größer machen, kleiner machen, bewegen und sowas.
Aber K-Win ist...
Heißt das nicht Kompositor mittlerweile unter Wayland, wenn man korrekt Wayland-Sachen verwenden will?
Ich meine, darauf geschissen, aber ich blick da bei Wayland noch nicht so genau durch, wo da die Unterschiede sind.
Das ist auch in diesem Fall der Kompositor.
Ah, siehste? Siehste, siehste.
...die Fenster zu einem finalen Bild zusammensetzt, euch Schatten, Transparenz und Animationen verwaltet.
Ihr könnt K-Win das aber auch einfach wegnehmen und dann sowas wie I3 draufwerfen, wenn ihr das wollt.
Zumindest im klassischen X11-Modus.
Dann könnt ihr durch eure Desktop-Fenster durchschneiden, wie ein Ninja, und sie halbieren.
Das ist das Tiling, was ich vorhin meinte.
Das nennt sich Tiling Window Manager.
Ist aber für meinen Kopf ein bisschen anstrengend gewesen.
Und ich habe das eine Weile ausprobiert, aber mein Kopf wurde wohl...
Also, ich bin großer Tiling Window Manager-Fan.
deswegen verwende ich ja mein KDE
im Endeffekt wie einen Tiling Window Manager
Fullscreen Browser, Fullscreen Terminal
und im Terminal wird dann halt geteilt, wenn man es braucht
oder getappt
und hier Fullscreen, Fullscreen
das einzige was ich halt nicht habe jetzt in KDE
ist, dass die Dinger automatisch geteilt werden
ja guck, wenn ich jetzt ein neues Terminal hier aufmache
ist es erstmal so dummes Overlay
da muss man die irgendwie so von Hand teilen
ja, das habe ich jetzt nicht mehr
aber das brauche ich eh nicht, weil ich teile ja
in einem Terminal
Aber wenn ich jetzt hier sagen würde, ich mache hier noch ein Terminal auf,
dann ist es halt nicht.
Ich weiß, das geht irgendwie auch.
Es gibt irgendwie die Möglichkeit, dass du KDE auch automatisch teilen lassen kannst.
Ja, ja.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich brauche das nicht.
Weil, was benutze ich?
Ich benutze Browser.
Einfach ein Browser im Fullscreen.
Ich benutze Terminal.
Ein Terminal im Fullscreen, beziehungsweise wenn ich mehrere Terminals brauche,
wird hier drin gesplittet oder getappt.
Ja.
dann hier
Editor, IDE, was auch immer offen
und hier Chaterino im Fullscreen
so
das heißt, wenn hier jetzt die IDE im Fullscreen läuft
oder keine Ahnung, Visual Studio Code oder
whatever
hatten wir hier übrigens anscheinend noch nie drauf
auf, dann wird hier was
gemacht und zum Ausprobieren wird dann hier einfach
ins Terminal geswitcht
also
einziges Setup, was ich jetzt
hier so noch nicht ausprobiert hab
ist, was ich unter dem
Tiling Window Manager manchmal
gemacht habe, ist,
ich habe mein, ich habe mir hier,
kann man das vielleicht so machen? Ja.
Ja, süß, okay, lässt sich auch machen. Ich habe mir
manchmal hier einen Terminal gemacht, ja,
um dann hier drin irgendwas zu
watchen, was passiert.
Oder aber, was ich auch manchmal, was ich auch öfters
mal gemacht habe, ist,
umgedreht hier an den
Boden angeheftet,
sodass ich es dann quasi irgendwie
so hatte, ja.
aber da gibt es
es gibt Tiling Shortcuts
bei KDE
und ich benutze nicht das eingebaute
Visual Studio Code Terminal, weil das
sagt
es gibt Tiling Shortcuts in KDE, damit
kann man das auch relativ schnell machen
habe ich aber bis jetzt hier noch nicht gebraucht, ansonsten
sieht halt meine Desktop-Aufteilung so auf Browser
Fullscreen Terminal, wo geteilt werden kann
Editor-Ede
Fullscreen und hier noch was
oder halt, also reicht in der Regel
ja vollkommen zufrieden mit ich bin teiling window manager fern und ich verändere mein kde im prinzip
auch wie die teile benutzt du workspace ist ja klar guck hier erster workspace browser zweiter
workspace terminal dritter workspace gerade leer vierter workspace chatarino er wächst workspace
ohne workspace das kann ich nicht arbeiten was ich überhaupt nicht kann ist das wie das ich sag
Ich nenne es jetzt mal die Noobs machen.
Die hier ihre Sachen aufhaben.
Alles übereinander.
Und dann immer hier rumklicken müssen.
So, ich brauche jetzt doch das Setting.
Oh, wo habe ich denn jetzt hier das Terminal?
Also da kriege ich, dieser Windows-Workflow, da kriege ich richtig krasse Anfälle bei.
Aber ansonsten geht das.
Ich habe gerade Essen gekriegt.
Wir müssen das Video aber noch irgendwie fertig gucken.
Kannst ein bisschen abkühlen.
Okay, hast du Hotkeys für einzelne Workspaces
oder tappst du durch?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man durchtappt.
Wie tappt man denn durch überhaupt?
Also ich hab Hotkeys für die einzelnen Workspaces.
Windows-Taste 1,
Windows-Taste 2, Windows-Taste 3,
Windows-Taste 4 hab ich.
Wie man da durchtappt?
Okay, mit dem Mausrad anscheinend irgendwie.
Oder auch nicht. Oder whatever.
Keine Ahnung, wie der Scheiß funktioniert.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ich tapp da durch.
Also deswegen benutze ich auch maximal 5 Workspaces, weil Windows Taste 5 erreicht man noch halbwegs ohne sich zu verrenken. Aber 1, 2, 3, 4 ist halt easy.
Was ich beispielsweise auch nicht benutze, ist das Startmenü
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wofür ich das Startmenü benutzen soll
Ich hab den Anwendungslauncher, ja
Da kann ich alles drüber starten, was ich starten will
Beispielsweise auch superhübsche Sachen wie XDR
Oder halt den Clipboard-Manager
Der mir den Clipboard-Manager am Maus einblendet
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel hier mir Sachen kopiere
So das da, das da und das da
So und ich will jetzt das vorletzte wieder haben
dann nehme ich das einfach aus dem Clipboard Manager und füge das hier ein.
Probier mal Ctrl Alt Rechte Pfeiltaste.
Nö, geht nicht.
Aber Ctrl Windows Rechte Pfeiltaste und so geht.
Wie unter Windows, witzigerweise.
Das geht. Aber brauche ich nicht.
Ich tappe immer.
Weil ich weiß, ich muss ja nicht durchtappen, weil ich weiß ja, wo was ist.
Wenn ich Terminal will, weiß ich, ich muss auf die 2.
Wenn ich Browser will, weiß ich, ich muss auf die 3.
Wenn ich in den Edit-Top IDE will, weiß ich, ich muss auf die 3.
... wohl offensichtlich zu viele Jahre von Windows frittiert.
Über KWin liegen dann Notifications, Panels und die eigentlichen Fenster,
die aber dasselbe Framework nutzen.
Dolphin ist das Ding, in dem ihr eure Dateien anschauen könnt.
Oh, dieses Theme, da krieg ich echt auch Gänsehaut.
Die Konsole ist das Ding, in dem ich lebe.
Aber das ist ja das Schöne an Linux, jeder kann das so customizen, wie er das gerne hätte.
Welchen Clipboard-Manager benutzt du? Den Default-KDE-Clipboard-Manager?
Äh.
Keine Ahnung.
Clipboard. KDE-Clipboard.
Das Standard-Ding.
Ich hab halt nur Shortcut.
Ich hab halt nur Shortcut hier, dass der...
dass der Amos-Zeiger quasi
pop-upt.
Ich weiß nicht, welche...
Der Standard hat mir nicht eingebaut.
Übrigens, eine Sache fehlt mir noch.
Da gucken wir doch gerade mal, ob es das hier gibt.
Gibt es einen Timer vielleicht?
Timer?
Ah ja!
Kann man das jetzt
Shit
Ich bin immer zu dumm KDE zu benutzen
Was das was diese
Wie kann ich denn jetzt
Die Anordnung hier ändern
Show panel
Configuration
Äh
So
Ah ja
Okay gut
Da kann ich jetzt Timer setzen okay
Das ist besser als mein selbstprogrammierter
timer auf jeden fall stop start
und wenn das
stop
wenn das sagen wir mal jetzt nur auf zehn sekunden ist und ich starte es
gibt es dann gibt es eine ordentliche notification oder
Ne, ich lass das Standard-Theme.
Da wird es immer auch bei neuen Features
abgedatet. Okay, ja.
Kann man so lassen. Brauch ich manchmal.
Lass ich jetzt mal hier oben. Ah!
Richtig gut! Du kannst den Kram sogar
mit Maustaste machen. Allerdings nicht
wo du bist.
Okay, gut. Gefällt mir. Nice. Lass mal
eingeblendet.
Sogenannte Widgets.
Das Startmenü ist nur ein Widget.
Die Uhr ist nur ein Widget. Das System-Tray ist auch nur ein Widget und darin liegen dann die einzelnen Trays, also zum Beispiel Lautstärke einstellen, Netzwerk, Bluetooth und Co.
Das ist alles in diesem System-Tray drin. Im Grunde ist alles erstmal ein Widget, aber ihr könnt auch Widgets einfach nachinstallieren oder selbst entwickeln.
Das ist das, was wir tun.
Und sexy as hell wird es dann mit KIO.
KDE kann Netzwerk.
Nehmen wir mal Nass.
Die Dateien liegen nicht auf meinem PC, aber es fühlt sich so an, als würden sie auf meinem PC liegen,
weil es einfach wie ein ganz normaler Ordner eingebunden ist.
Das ganze KDE Plasma ist ein riesiger Sandkasten und ich liebe es mittlerweile einfach hier Sandburgen zu bauen.
Das kann ich verstehen. KDE ist halt mega customizable.
Das sieht man allein schon daran.
Ein schönes Beispiel ist, wenn wir mal jetzt hier die KDE-Konsole aufmachen.
Wir starten ja, also als Terminal verwende ich Westterm, aber das ist das KDE, das Terminal, mit dem KDE kommt.
Wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt, du hast hier, ich bin zu dumm,
wie komme ich hier auf die Settings?
Was?
Das meine ich nicht.
Hier, Profiles.
Ah, man muss ein neues Profile annehmen.
Guck mal hier, du kannst wirklich,
du kannst alles mögliche customizen bei KDE.
Das ist teilweise so krass,
dass es schon zu viel customizable ist,
was du in KDE machen kannst, ja.
Oder auch dieser Standard Text Editor,
mit dem KDE kommt.
Wenn du hier in die Settings gehst, Alter,
WTF,
kannst du alles customizen, ja.
Mein Terminal kann ich allerdings nur über den Text-Hardtry customizen
Ist ja auch kein KDE-Terminal
Und danke fürs Zuhören
Und achso, dazu sollte man sagen
All diese Software, KDE, Linux
Und auch jede Distro, die ich hier erwähnt habe
Kostet einfach gar nichts, hat keine Werbung
Und ist natürlich Open Source
Es ist irgendwie eine komplett verrückte Welt, oder?
Ich bin ehrlich mit euch
Mal solchen positiven Content zu machen
Tut mir wahnsinnig gut
und ich hoffe euch auch.
Falls ja, es würde mich tatsächlich wirklich verletzen,
wenn YouTube das hier mal wieder abstraft,
so wie sie es immer tun,
wenn ich ein bisschen positiver werden möchte,
weil es ja nicht mit der Angst der Leute spielt oder so.
Deswegen wäre ich euch wirklich dankbar,
wenn ihr das Video an jemand anderen schicken könntet.
Nur eine Person, die ihr vielleicht...
Also Leute, ich schicke euch mal das Video weiter,
könnt ihr eine Runde liken.
Für Leute, die vermutlich mehr Sinn für Schönes haben,
gibt es tatsächlich aber auch mehr als genug online.
Auf Reddit zum Beispiel, im Subreddit,
r slash unix porn.
Ja, das lese ich auch öfters.
Dort stellen richtig kreative
Menschen ihre besten Setups vor.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob da Niri immer noch
das Angesagteste ist, was die Leute posten.
Also in
Reddit, Subreddit, Unix Porn,
ist gefühlt so alle
alle zwei, drei, ach
alle eins bis zwei Monate wechselt
so die Hype-Plattformer durch.
Der hier hat sich einfach mal ein eigenes
Widget erstellt, das live
einmal alles anpassen kann.
Ich glaube, das zeigt, was hier wie schnell einfach möglich ist.
Live, ohne dass man irgendwie rebooten muss oder sowas.
Denn am Ende ist halt hier alles einfach nur Style und Widgets, wo ihr das Panel hin tun wollt.
Welche Farbe es hat, welches Look and Feel.
Das ist alles einfach nur...
Jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
Was zeigt er denn jetzt?
Ist das Niri?
Oder Hyperland.
Der hier hat sich einfach mal...
Achso, der zeigt die Sachen von Unix-Porn.
Wie schnell einfach möglich ist, live, ohne dass man irgendwie rebooten muss oder sowas.
Denn am Ende ist halt hier alles einfach nur Style und Widgets.
Wo ihr das Panel hin tun wollt, welche Farbe es hat, welches Look und Feel.
Das ist alles einfach nur eine Definitionssache.
Und auch wie die Widgets irgendwie verteilt sind.
Dieses kreative Genie hier hat einfach mal seine Fenster mit Physik versehen.
sodass sie einfach nach unten bouncen
und runterfallen
was ich auch witzig fand ist
einer der
Wim3D gemacht hat
äh
den meine ich
by the way gar nicht
irgendjemand hat Wim
auf so einem 3D Würfel laufen
Das ist auch was ganz abgedrehtes gewesen.
Ja.
Dafür weiß er nicht,
wie man mit FFM-Pack gute GIFs rendert.
Warum?
Weil es geht.
Diese Person hier einmal übertrieben hat
und natürlich gibt es auch
Game-Inspired-Themes wie dieses hier.
Also davon würde ich ja Augenkrebs kriegen,
wenn mein Desktop so aussieht.
Die Ideen dort sind so unfassbar kreativ
und haben mich vielleicht inspiriert, auch mal sowas machen zu wollen.
Ich spiele derzeit Persona 5 Royal mit meiner Freundin zusammen.
Das war eine Empfehlung eines Freundes, nachdem wir von Expedition 33 so begeistert waren.
Ich habe Expedition 33 immer noch nicht durchgespielt.
Ich habe auch leider sehr wenig Zeit zum Zocken.
Und trotzdem bin ich laut Steam schon bei 300 Stunden.
Bitte was?
Anyways, in der Zeit habe ich tatsächlich den Style, also diese Art Direction, richtig lieben gelernt.
Er ist sehr markant, muss man dazu sagen, und finde ich zumindest absolut einzigartig.
Atlas, also der Hersteller von Persona 5, nennt das Konzept von Persona 5 Pop-Punk.
Der Stil kommt vom Art Director Masayoshi Suto.
Und ihr seht den extrem hohen Kontrast aus Rot, Schwarz und Weiß.
Ach, jetzt kriegen wir gezeigt, wie er sein Team gebaut hat.
... komplett euch überlassen.
Aber schließen, maximieren oder minimieren,
das ist nämlich auch, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, oder?
Plus einfache Befehle, auch Auslastung.
auslastung das muss ich jetzt nicht angucken aber erste hälfte vom video sehr gut zusammengefasst
exzellent das team ist für meinen geschmack bis den augenkrebs aber wie gesagt das schöne
ist ja dass unter linux dass jeder so machen kann wie es ihm gefällt
und wahrscheinlich würden auch viele sagen über das verwendest du da wobei wahrscheinlich nicht
so viele, weil das halt ziemlich default
Cache-iOS mittlerweile ist hier.
Ich glaube, außer, ich glaube, wir haben
gar nichts geändert hier großartig.
Wir haben die Auflösung
angepasst und die Wiederholrate
vom Bildschirm, aber ansonsten haben wir nicht wirklich viel geändert.
Die Config für mein
Terminal und ganzes Gedöns hier
habe ich alles vom alten Rechner oder beziehungsweise
von der VM übernommen.
Ansonsten
nicht so viel am Start
hier oder so.
So, ich habe aber hier was zu essen stehen, Leute.
Heute Mittag, heute Nachmittag
kann es sein,
dass ich nochmal online komme
und wir eine Runde
Rast
programmieren.
USB-Gedöns.
Hast du jetzt Burger bestellt?
Nee, ich habe hier noch Fisch,
so eine Art,
es sieht aus wie große Fischstäbchen
und Kartoffelsalat.
Ich habe mir keinen Burger bestellt.
Deswegen, Leute, wir sehen uns dann, vielleicht schon Nachmittag.
Wem das Schreiben gefallen hat, ich würde mich sehr über einen Follow freuen.
Könnt auch mal bei Morpheus im Video vorbeigucken und da ein Like da lassen.
Wie gesagt, wenn es ihm hilft, ich gucke die Videos von ihm auch immer sehr gern.
Und bis dann, Leute. Macht's gut. Wir sehen uns.
See you.